this is the Jocko podcast number 397
with Echo Charles and me Jocko willink
good evening Echo good evening
the president of the United States takes
pleasure in presenting the Legion of
Merit to Captain Matthew T provencher
medical Corps United States Navy for
exceptionally meritorious conduct in the
performance of outstanding service as
the command medical officer at four sea
air and land Seal Team 17 from June 2013
to June
2022. Captain provincher displayed
extraordinary leadership world-class
professional expertise and provided
unmatched care and treatment for the
service members within his command and
throughout the naval special Warfare
Community he was instrumental in
Implement in the implementation of
policy processes and procedures that
optimize the operational Readiness of
both reserve and active Force seal
operators a world-renowned orthopedic
surgeon and educator he delivered
databases to track treatment efficacy
wearable devices that provided remote
assessment of individual motion patterns
and Leading Edge science that will
improve Human Performance and longevity
his contributions extend far beyond the
naval special Warfare medical community
to programs and cutting-edge science
treatments that have been adopted by the
Navy and Department of Defense
Captain preventers Superior performance
of Duties culminated in his 27 years of
honorable and dedicated military service
by his Dynamic Direction Keen judgment
and loyal dedication to duty Captain
provencher reflected great credit upon
himself and upheld the highest
traditions of the United States Naval
service
and that is an award that's
that's actually an understatement
it's an understatement for someone that
had a huge impact on the SEAL Teams
putting broken seals back together
I had one of my friends tell me about
Doc and he said he repaired both my left
and right shoulders my left one after a
vehicle rolled over in Iraq 2008 he's
been a huge reason I've been able to
keep pushing my body so hard
him and others like him are the unsung
heroes of the SEAL Teams
helping hurt and damaged guys come back
and operate again
I and so many other seals appreciate him
with the greatest sincerity
and that is the truth
guys in the SEAL Teams
get broken
it's a rough job
it is a rough job and guys like Doc
preventer
put us back together again
and on top of that this group that he
headed up spearheaded injury prevention
optimal Human Performance including
strength and conditioning nutrition
brain health mental Wellness
and they do this with experience
knowledge and patriotic passion
and and an unmitigated commitment to the
SEAL Teams
well after being the lead medical
officer for the SEAL Teams for almost a
decade and then working at Mass General
in Boston and being the head team
physician and medical doctor for the New
England Patriots doc preventer certainly
has some incredible knowledge on all
these different topics
and it's an honor to have him here
tonight to pass on his experiences and
Lessons Learned
from this vast experience doc
thanks for joining us
Echo Charles it's a great pleasure thank
you truly honored to be here tonight so
we we have to recap of something here
because once again you are another
Witness
and I believe the first time I remember
interacting with you was to check my
bicep which had been injured I was doing
Jiu Jitsu at my my bicep had popped made
a noise and I came in to the what we
call the human performance center what
was it called yeah medical yeah
performance yeah I go into the medical
right and I I go in there
and I see Jason who's who helped me with
some little tweaks here and there
to look at my bicep you did an
assessment on my bicep what was your
assessment of my bicep
in Jacqueline and what I recall was you
were in some kind of hold and uh you
know you felt this pop pretty classic at
the elbow
it's almost always a rupture of the
biceps tendon where it attaches into
your forearm and it's pretty important
for someone like you and what you want
to do be able to move the forearm right
and also biceps hold and looked at torn
your biceps and in general for someone
like you that's something we take to
surgery to fix because you need to have
that right
so you said to me hey look Jocko here's
the situation you got its own bicep and
this won't heal
this is you need to get surgery and you
schedule the surgery right there you
have the little computer system you
schedule the surgery and it was maybe
three four weeks away and you said okay
in whatever this date come back in here
for your pre-operation check I said
Roger that you know I'm one of those
people if I got a problem and you tell
me how I'm going to fix it I'm ready to
go like I'm not going to wait around
let's do it so
I come back three weeks later for my
pre-op pre-operation tests checkup and
you're there and you look at my bicep
and what had happened
I couldn't believe it but it actually
healed I mean yeah no strength deficits
you had
complete restoration of function I I
don't know what happened I mean you knew
something was wrong a couple weeks prior
and it's kind of the first time we could
get you in for surgery and we had to get
you in a couple weeks before this tendon
gut the muscle got too atrophied and was
harder to repair but
I said what the heck is going on here
this thing is I'm done I'm testing and
I'm like Jason Jackson's there and I'm
like Jason what's going on he's like
I don't know it's healed he's got full
strength he's ready to go back in the
fight so there you go Echo Charles so
Echo has he he told me when I first
explained this because he's had both
biceps torn both bicep tendons torn he's
had surgery on both arms and I told him
after his first one or maybe after a
second one I said you know when I that
happened to me I just healed it
and he did not believe me he did not
believe it was until we had doc parsley
on here and confirmed and now we've got
the second witness yeah Echo do you
accept now that Wolverine blood is a
real thing so one doc personally came on
I was like he was like saying it I was
like there's something you guys are
missing here I know that already but I
was 50 convinced so I was like okay
maybe you know he's a doctor after all
so whatever and then yes yes sir I
believe it now this is the other 50
right now has been confirmed so I think
and I think I remember talking to
parsley about that as well and I was
like what's going on with the uh the
system here this is almost always
something we fixed there's no tend in
there it's like the one of the easier
diagnoses we make
I've I feel like I'm pretty lucky I've
been you know actually Echo you
described to me one time
as being durable yeah and I would say
I'm not I'm definitely not the strongest
person I'm not the fastest person I'm
not the smartest person but my durabu my
durability level seems to be good very
good we're appreciative of that so uh
doc seriously um all the guys know what
you've done in the SEAL Teams and how
many people you've helped and it's not
just the SEAL Teams because you were
working on everybody in the military and
we'll get into that but let's start off
with the beginning let's start off about
how you became who you are let's go
where'd you start born in New Hampshire
is that right yeah we're in a really
small town Jocko in New Hampshire we
maybe 2500 people a place where the the
General Store is the post office didn't
have a traffic light we didn't have
cable TV we had
a Channel or two maybe on the television
with the antenna that you had to my dad
and I had to get up there and fix all
the time you had a little dial they
couldn't point the antenna to get the
better signal on this motor we got that
motor it was great we didn't have to go
out and rotate it manually yoke and then
the ice and the snow and everything
would Jack it all up so we we grew up in
the woods and we were close enough to
the beach that we took care of advantage
of uh took advantage of everything out
in New England and New Hampshire it was
a great place to grow up as a kid I love
being outside what'd your dad do my dad
so my dad was a Naval Academy grad oh
okay uh he was in the Navy for a while I
was born in Newport Rhode Island
actually and then we moved up to New
Hampshire and he was by trade an
engineer for a number of different
companies was he a surface Warfare
officer in the Navy he was and you know
what's interesting Joko he had USMC
inscribed in his Naval Academy ring but
at the last minute switched interesting
what year was that that was 1969 he
graduated what made him make that
decision I don't know I mean I think it
was different time zone I think I didn't
remember Vietnam War
I think there were some changes there
and you know mindset and you know when I
was in the Naval Academy with some many
of your great colleagues in the SEAL
Teams we I it was a great place to be
and I know it was very good when he was
there but the the political climate made
it sometimes a challenge to be at a
place like Annapolis
so how long did he do in the Navy so he
did he did just over five years and got
out of Newport Rhode Island then we
moved up and they moved up to New
Hampshire and and after I was born and
and my brother also uh was born a few
years after me he's three years younger
and he also went to the Naval Academy
and he got the much better genetics as I
say because he's the uh he's the F-18
pilot I wanted to fly f-18s at you know
with the Naval Academy that's why I went
Top Gun first one it just come out I
mean it was great like oh this is
awesome I want to be able to fly a jet
or be a seal or uh but while I went to
the academy my eyes went down to like 20
50. yeah and he didn't have any recourse
and so that's sort of how I defaulted
into medicine my brother got the good
eye so he's the F-18 now guys get Lasik
I know now for the teams can you get
Lasik for flying too you can yeah yeah
so you can get uh PRK Lasik they had a
bunch of different rules and then what
you can and can't do based you know
because of the G's and the pressure and
the dive and the unique requirements so
it's definitely opened it up to more
people that just because of eyesight
couldn't go before so before you got
there before you went to the Naval
Academy you're going up in high school
what sports did you play we did a lot of
uh Team Sports basketball baseball the
usual stuff around there do a lot of
skiing did a lot of back country did a
lot of backpacking did a lot of uh I
worked for the forest service actually
and it was with their kind of mountain
Patrol Mountain Rescue so we're always I
guess it was probably my first
introduction to Medicine I know into my
family was in medicine Jocko so I had no
idea what this was you know a career was
going to take me or what I was going to
do we knew Navy we knew military in my
family but didn't know medicine did you
so did you know from basically this time
you started looking at colleges that you
were going to try and go to the Naval
Academy I I had looked at a bunch of
different colleges but it was it was
definitely high on the list definitely
because of Top Gun because I wanted to
fly because I want to be a seal because
I wanted to do these things
was it hard to get in how hard was it to
get in
it was hard yeah there's a lot of you
know there's a lot of extra things you
got to do but you know you go through
the process you know what to do you know
how to do the interviews with your
Congressional Congressional folks your
senators in the state and then you do
the you know just like another college
application there's a few more Hoops you
got to jump through but you were getting
good grades this whole time I was I was
doing fine
um during high school and we had a
really good high school as a public
school that we went to my parents
actually had an amazing sacrifice they
had to drive my brother and I to high
school about you know 20 25 30 minutes
every day and sometimes we got rides
with folks but I mean there was no bus
service to the high school we went to so
we had to kind of figure that out and
after school things and now I'm forever
indebted and thankful for them to give
me that opportunity and you but you get
into the Naval Academy and you show up
to uh cleave summer how's that go
uh miserable it was awful Doug was
freaking awful I was like
why because this guy does not do well in
heat I go to Annapolis Maryland and it's
like 99 degrees 100 humidity and I was
like this is gonna put me over the edge
I'm like I'm gonna be out here in a week
but you know fortunately just uh I was
able to find ways around it find a way
to adapt and you sort of get used to it
I mean you know you deployed forever in
different environments and weather and
condition and everything and the the
stress of of weather can't be
overestimated in our field you know in
the military it's amazing and so just
bleep summer was part of that package
for six seven eight weeks and I I
thought I was gonna like
be out of there in a week what about
just like all the you know shocking off
people yelling and screaming you just
prepared for that medley and you knew
what was coming
yeah I did you need and you know it's
not personal like but it's hard you're
starting you know you're 18 years old
you're starting freshman year and you're
like oh what's going on with this and
why are they after me why are they
selling me out and anyway you know
you're just like what did I do wrong I
didn't make my turn right I didn't make
my bed right convince the right quarter
off it my t-shirts weren't lined up
right there was always something they
would find there was a speck of dust
here there's a speck of dust there but
the it what was amazing about that
process when you look back the attention
to detail the ability to quickly
memorize facts figures information was
just amazing and my brain sort of worked
that way a little bit but it certainly
got fine-tuned there to be able to
memorize stuff really quickly
Michigan preventer noon meal go what is
it and it changes every noon okay menu
for your new meal go and we all know
that from the yellow Academy like just
all these facts and everything you got
to memorize there again and again and
again we're like why are we doing this
stuff when you walk away you're like I
really trained my brain incredibly well
so when I went to medical school I was
like
yeah I don't want to say easy but it was
yeah I was ready yeah so you you are
going through the Naval Academy now and
what was your major
yeah so I I still wanted to fly I didn't
know you you have to you do your medical
junior year it's called your
pre-commissioning physical and so I
didn't really know my eyes was kind of
squinting a little bit to see the board
I did have some glasses
but it wasn't that bad you know I think
it was fixable enough that I could do it
so I studied engineering and it was
actually electrical engineering myself
of all things and so
um not biology not oceanography not some
of these other Majors that could be a
little bit uh
more leaning to doing medical as a
career so I was probably the
anti-non-medical and um
you know with that we also did some you
know leadership positions and other
things that you know all of my mentors
there you know thought I was going into
the regular Fleet I was not I was going
to be a line officer I was going to be a
staff Corps medical staff Corps and
you're do you were a rower right I was
Joko yeah and then how did you get into
that
so I had done a little bit in New
Hampshire growing up and then I during
bleep summer they rotate you around
through every sport they make you play
squash and go out to do football and
baseball and they take you out to the
rowing facility and so everyone sort of
goes through all these Sports every
afternoon part of police somewhere it's
like a it wasn't bleep summer it'd be a
great Camp because we could do every
sport at the Naval Academy the
facilities are amazing
and uh that's I was like man this is
pretty cool Boathouse is a good spot I
like the people here I like the the
workout I like the ethic I like the ERG
machine I like the weights and and
staying in shape and get in shape and I
liked also just being out in the water
I'm a water guy I like the water that's
why I picked the Navy over some like Air
Force or West Point which I also applied
to so did you get into Western
I did yeah I didn't
um I think I don't know Air Force might
have waitlisted me or something but I
wasn't going to go there so you're doing
rowing and but you end up being a pretty
good rower is that correct well you know
I mean joggers you know Rowan's a team
sport team team effort but there's
always all these individual tests what
they associate on the ERG and all these
bench pulls and things like that and uh
you know did did okay but we you know it
was a team sport and kind of the
ultimate team sport that as I think of
it and you know certainly others will
disagree with me but the amount of
precision required to get you know the
ore and exactly the right point
something milliseconds and it just makes
the boat go better it almost lifts and
takes off and it's effortless and so to
have that Precision the strength the
application of force at the right time
to know the right technique is really
um it just appealed to me I love Ron my
brother also rode and he was a very good
rower much better than I was and he did
some you know Olympic teams you know
tryout stuff in and out but I did a
little bit of national team try out
stuff in and out for the a couple years
after the Naval Academy and and for a
couple years after so you know they sort
of test you and look at how you do on
the ERG and see how you move the boat
what can you roll 500 in to be
competitive for that 500 meters yeah so
you probably looking at 1 30 or under
125 check so 120 now I am not the
biggest role I was in and out of a
lightweight heavyweight we have a
lightweight category so
you know my brother make fun of me
because he's six five and 225 and he's
not a lightweight so he would uh crush
the ERG but for the my body class was a
pretty good pretty good time you go to
the world rowing the world ERG
championships in Boston they had every
year and you compete against all these
people from Denmark and so those were I
mean those are kind of fun to to see and
and it was a great existence for me
while I was there at the Naval Academy I
made it a great a great great team a
great Sport and just really completed
the package for me there are you doing
that sport year round
yeah we are really consumed you're
consumed your life but in a good way
so you said in junior year is when you
get your medical and how long after you
get your medical do they look at you and
say hey you can't see well enough to
have any of these jobs that you want to
have
right away they're like here's your list
and they just hand you the list and okay
where uh what ship do you want do you
want to go Marines do you want to do
these other things surface Warfare
officer Etc
and I said well I mean those are all
great I'm not against my data service
Warfare officers we discussed but I
didn't know where I I don't know really
where I wanted to go and I had a couple
great mentors one of them being
this guy Dean Kelly my dad goes to me
he's like Dad I don't know what to do
like I got disqualified for flight
disqualified for seal all these other
things he's like all right go see my
chemistry professor there his name my
name is Dean John Kelly and he was
actually my dad's chemistry professor
but he had kind of fleeted up to dean of
the entire academic side civilian Dean
not the military
sign they have two sides a military and
a civilian side and I go in and see Dean
John Kelly and his classic media I go in
there
reporting and so I'll get in here
prevention at least I need to talk to
you yeah you got some pretty good grades
here your electrical engineer okay
here's the deal
I pulled your dad's folder hold on he
rips his you know his classic Professor
books everywhere dust stacks of files
and folders and open it up in the
folders my dad's he's like oh you're I
tried to get your dad to go to medicine
but he wanted to go be a marine or
something I don't know I had something
written down and my dad's folder from
1967 or eight or something like that
before he graduated he's like you ever
thought about medicine you know and he's
like well my dad sent me here to talk to
you he's you got a great connection with
him and
it's amazing you're still here and he's
like well I run the medical program here
at Naval Academy we allow 15 graduates a
year to service Select Medical
I said tell me more about that sir I'm
very interested
what was it that was in your mind
because
because that they couldn't sold me on
the medical program what so you did you
have some like nascent thought about
being a doctor at some point
only that we did some ski patrol stuff
we did some of that mountain Patrol the
forest service we took some of these
Wilderness you know first aid courses
that you had to do to be able to do that
that was really my only introduction I
had no idea like even how long medical
school was what it was or how to do it
or what even a residency I had no clue
about any of this stuff and they take 15
people 15 out of about 1200 ish or so we
graduate yeah
so you decide at that point like that's
what it took did you that was it I did
but I you know to be honest I was a
little nervous about it because I had a
couple jobs I had a leadership job I was
a deputy Brigade Commander the second in
command of the at the time we're trying
to sort through it and and uh this guy
Colonel Terry Murray who was very well
known he became went on to become a
general with his Colonel at the time
he's the deputy commandant and the
commandant with Shiba and the
superintendent and you get to know these
folks through all these leadership
events and you go and have uh you know
just incredible opportunities at that
place you know like Professor get over
you need to go to dinner at the
superintendent so I was like oh what's
going on I gotta go study I just tired
I'm just working out just to finish
rowing or like well it's uh Margaret
Thatcher you got to go hang out you know
see you get like some really cool
experiences looking back when you're at
a 15 person dinner and you know a couple
midshipmen there and they yanked you to
go so I I I'm very very thankful for
that but at the end of the day I still
still had no idea what the hell I was
getting into
so then what's the application process
like to get into the medical program
yeah so I I finished up at the Naval
Academy not to bore you with too many
details but I didn't have all the
requirements I was gonna say did they
make you start taking other classes on
biology or whatever yeah and I did but I
didn't have enough time and so Dean
Kelly was like prevention you gotta
graduate electrical engineering we need
you know we got to keep our electoral
Engineering Graduate numbers up we've
got some site visits from whatever
academic organization that follows call
and just whatever and you gotta we'd
love for you to stay and graduate double
e and then we'll find a way to make it
happen that you can finish up your
requirements and take biology and
organic chemistry and a couple others I
actually had most of them you know the
well-roundedness of the education the
Naval Academy is amazing so I had almost
all of them but I needed a couple and so
it actually worked out that I was going
to be trying out rowing working with the
U.S national team out of Boston and
Philadelphia Princeton San Diego we had
a couple different setups going on and
but mostly based out of Boston and
that's where I started taking my classes
after I graduated worked worked there I
was in the Navy so they gave you some
kind of a normal job some kind of a
gap-filled job and then you could go to
school where are you going to school I
went to Boston College Boston University
just took these just took whatever it is
with a bunch of freshmen and sophomores
it was great it was great and in the
meantime you're applying to medical
school meant to implanted medical school
and then you get into medical school I
do get into medical school I was a
little worried because I was taking all
these you have to take this ridiculously
long like seven hour test called the
medcat which is the Medical College
admission test and it's
I I look back on that now and I was like
I I didn't have really biology when I
took the test I never heard that so I
kind of learned it on my own and I I did
I didn't blow it out of the water but I
didn't okay to get some looks at schools
and then I ended up um getting in
several places not a lot I got rejected
at a bunch and I was like ah this sucks
what am I gonna do and the Navy's the
Navy's calling me and they're like hey
we need to get a we need to see a letter
of admission from a medical school or
we've got a ship for you waiting uh and
some prevention down here in Newport
Rhode Island you're gonna go to swa so
the U.S has never dock you got it I was
like ah dang it I mean I gotta get this
letter and so I finally got into a
couple schools and was able to uh get on
the letter and then where'd you end up
going you end up going to Dartmouth I
did Jocko yeah I went back up to my
roots up in New Hampshire up at
Dartmouth and I was four years of
medical school up there and I loved
every minute how crazy was that you go
from the being a plebe and then a
midshipman at the Naval Academy you got
people yelling at you and all these
uniforms you got to wear all day did you
have to do any of that at Dartmouth
well actually the only thing I did was
kind of fun stuff they made you do like
45 days of active duty training because
I was on a four-year deferment from
medical for medical school so didn't
wear the uniform I think I are you
getting your Navy pay you're getting the
instant pay no no not at all now if I
had gone to the military Medical School
Eustis in Bethesda that you would be
active duty during that time so I was
not active duty for four years
so they basically and it's a great deal
it's called hpsp but it's a scholarship
for those listed out there it's a great
deal I mean they I got out of you know
undergrad and med school with no debt
zero
and they you're not getting paid a lot I
mean you get a few hundred bucks a month
but they're covering tuition books and
fees which ain't cheap what about
housing
no just they give you a stipend per
month check it's a little bit different
when I was reading your bio I was like
oh he was going there over the big fat
paycheck I didn't know that you they
took your uh pay away from you that's
rough yeah it was a little it was a
little a little rough I I took a small
loan you know which obviously since paid
off but uh just just to get through
Dartmouth but it was it was a great four
years there I didn't I didn't forget my
hair cut every you know 10 14 days down
at the midship and barber shop I you
know maybe cut it every three to six
months and just did a lot of other stuff
and and focused on med school and and
living back up in New Hampshire how far
from like where you grew up what were
you at Dartmouth yeah it was about two
hours oh so you were going home for
Christmas and thanks again or whatever
yeah probably more often than that like
like mom's cooking and how hard is
medical school for you it must have
seemed like a little bit of a breeze I
mean honestly I know it was hard and all
that but compared to being at the Naval
Academy where you had these tests and
uniforms and inspections and all this
other stuff going on in your rowing like
you had a lot of stuff going on at the
Naval Academy now they're like oh no all
you have to do is study yeah they won't
juggle the most interesting thing for me
was you know the Naval Academy you got
no choice you've got to go to class and
you don't go the only way you can get
out of class is if you have a movement
order where you're going on a
rowing race you've got a varsity Rowing
competition up at Princeton or San Diego
or whatever that's the only way you're
you're getting out of it so I get to
Dartmouth and they're like hey are you
even gonna go to class are you going to
show up are you gonna I'm like what I
don't know what this means anyway I went
to a lot of the classes but not not all
my classmates did I just I just learned
well that way I was engaged you're
locked in you're you know fall in the
process you're with the you're with the
professors and and learning alongside
them so I didn't go to everything though
and it was kind of nice I didn't have to
like
sign all these like movement order
things to get out of stuff
do they have like fraternities up there
they do for uh undergrads I I wanted to
I wanted to join one you know somehow
because I didn't have it as an
underground but they've rejected you
because you were a post-grad too old
yeah yeah
now did while you're there do you is
that when you picked Orthopedics
I did yeah and and so this is
interesting I you know you you meet
these great people that help steer your
career along the way and I know
you've had that Jocko and you make
decisions and you don't know like going
to see John Kelly going to medical
school well I got injured you know Rowan
it's not like it's like being a seal and
all the injuries you get or an NFL
player but we're playing football in
college but I had a couple injuries that
took me out for a little bit of time in
rowing and during some critical times
and so
I went to see one of my first mentors
who I've learned was this guy uh Captain
Eddie McDevitt who's the head orthopedic
surgeon at the Naval Academy and took
care of all the sports injuries and I
learned
what is this this is kind of cool and so
what I didn't tell you is you know it
was a little easier for me to select
medicine because I had Dr McDevitt there
to help say this is a pretty cool career
you know you can do this and be a part
of uh
you know great community and give back
and do Orthopedics and serve the Navy in
other ways and so it was really good to
have that Mentor but
he helped he helped me see what sort of
sports medicine and Orthopedics was and
I said this is this is really cool now
of course I dated a bunch of other
Specialties like Dermatology and plastic
surgery Echo Charles we talked about
that for your biceps
implants over there
uh other other other things uh ENT and
Ophthalmology but I I wanted to use my
hands I wanted to use my hands in a
craft whether if I couldn't be using my
hands to be a sealers I couldn't do it
because I couldn't be a pilot to use my
hands I wanted to use my hands
and that's the weird thing about
Orthopedics is you're basically a
carpenter or a welder yeah like you have
a job to piece things back together
carpentry class 101 and that's so full
circle and you don't realize these
things you put them together in the in
your life they're you take a step back
and take a 30 000 foot view of your life
and like how your passion and your
energy and your drive sort of leads you
to these things this was a no-brainer
for me because I was an engineer I love
trying to figure things out I love
trying to put stuff together to figure
out metal on metal interactions implants
strengths the strength of the anchor we
were going to use to fix your biceps
Jocko we know the exact Newtons and the
strength and the suture and the material
and what it's made out of
and I was able to walk the walk and talk
the talk because I knew the language of
engineering and so for me Orthopedics
was
kind of this full circle I've arrived
now in the civilian World you'd go when
you get done and correct me if I'm wrong
because I don't know but in the civilian
world you get done with medical school
and then you go do your residency right
that's right pattern so that's basically
what you do
at this juncture in your career you get
done with Dartmouth you graduate you get
your degree and then you go to do your
is it your do they call it your
residency when you go to because you
went to Balboa right they do yeah I did
I went all right so Bob I was in San
Diego uh it's
one of the largest naval hospitals in
the world there's really three big
teaching hospitals there's Balboa San
Diego uh there's Bethesda and then
Portsmouth Virginia
and in essence I was going to go to one
of those three and one thing you do at
the Naval Academy is after your freshman
year you have to go do 30 60 days on a
ship and so in the summer Cruise you got
it so yeah exactly so
um
sophomore summer Cruise youngster Cruz
that's a youngster as a sophomore at the
Academy and so you go on youngster Cruz
and guess where they sent me
a kid from New Hampshire they brought
him all the way out west to San Diego
and I thought I had died and gone to
heaven I mean this is unbelievable he
got surfing you got good water it's not
freezing I can go in the water year
round it's not just three months a year
and New Hampshire when the water's cold
and I was like this is amazing and so
that sort of guided my way to get to San
Diego after because they were gonna just
like I got the letter you're either
going to med school or we got a ship for
you and some prevention now I'm
Lieutenant prevention and you're going
to be either going to San Diego Bethesda
or Portsmouth you'll let us know your
choices you don't always get your first
choice fortunately I did and just all
worked out so that's what this is 1998
when you get out here for the first time
this is 98 Taco yep and now you're just
you you check into uh Balboa is this the
residency like my friend Dr Peter attia
who did his residency at Johns Hopkins
and it was you tell he tells the stories
of just no sleep you know working 36 and
48 hour shifts was it like that at
Balboa for your residency was it was
there some kind of control yeah
so what's interesting is there there are
quite a few controls now and we call it
the quote-unquote 80 hour work week
which you're supposed to adhere to as a
easy hour work week you're supposed to
adhere to an 80 hour work week but I can
tell you oh during my entire training we
had none of those rules we had no 80
hour work week we had 110 120 hours
you're on the call night after night
maybe a day off we we were we were busy
and it was a uh it was a significant
burdened on you know the family of
burden on you know just being away and
and just time and on your your body and
we do it so much better now in what we
call graduate medical education gme it's
done so much better now in the United
States than what we did but it certainly
taught you the craft really well and but
sometimes function I mean as you know
when you're in here feel Jocko it's not
always the best to be functioning on you
know zero sleep and you're on your 55th
hour yeah it's just not the best it's
pretty disturbing actually when you
think about these young doctors and
they're getting they're awake for 55
hours and they're making a decision on
what they're going to do cutting you
open right that doesn't seem like the
best plan was that just like a cultural
thing was that a cultural thing where
that's how it was for me and that's how
it's going to be for you too yeah I mean
I I think that certainly is a part of it
and fortunately you know the wake-up
call came where we're now able to really
regulated you can only be on calls so
much if you're on call you got to go
home by a certain time the next day
which is basically you know late morning
so that rest and Recovery which we know
is so important in sleep Dr parsley is
so important and and you're just better
at your craft at the end of the day
so what's your job like when you get to
Balboa and this is so this is 1998 1999
there's no war going on you're dealing
with kind of normal
injuries like family injuries people you
know accidentally you know cut
themselves with a knife and they come in
or they break their leg on the
playground or playing basketball that's
what you're dealing with at this point
all the above yeah for sure and the
first you are I mean you're the very
bottom of the run I mean you're the
intern so your first year of internship
and there's a little bit of uncertainty
in the Navy if the Navy taught me
anything it was certainly patience and
you don't have to rush into everything
and I've got a lot of you know folks who
are able to Mentor now they're like I
want this look at this I gotta get them
I'm like calm down it's okay you're
gonna get there and I after my
internship here the Navy sent me to
Okinawa Japan for a year and I went
Kicking and Screaming because guess what
all my friends from Dartmouth they're
going straight through into residency
it's five years of Orthopedic training I
want to get through this I've done this
you know like I want to get done with it
but it ended up being one of the best
years in the maturity and the people you
meet and taking care of what were you
doing in Japan you're a general medical
officer you're you could be a flight
surgeon you could be a dive medical
officer but I opted to do the GMO route
it's a general medical route and so they
assigned me to a Marine base in Okinawa
Camp Courtney and this is funny they
actually said all right prevention you
went to the Naval Academy
um got a few of you here but you're the
only one doing this GMO Marine Corps
thing and
you got to be able to salute I know you
know how to salute okay so you're gonna
go to Camp Courtney which is basically
the headquarter
realm in
Okinawa because you'll be walking around
this base and you're going to be at
least representing us well know how to
salute because he went to the game
looking out at me and so I think that's
how I ended up there at least what my
boss told me so I went to Camp Courtney
and uh I would I was not entirely happy
about it I wanted to continue on
residency but that's just not how it
worked then and we went to Okinawa and
it ended up being the best year it was
just incredible and the experiences and
that's because you were in a position
where you were kind of the guy that's
right and you were the one that answered
the mail on whatever injuries were
coming across yeah that's right and you
know you're you're kind of like the
Town dock you know right there a name
but I don't know a ton I know enough and
you know when to refer but I've been
through like one year of residency in in
surgery you know surgical type of
residency and I don't I don't have any
special team at this point I'm not an
orthopedic surgeon and fortunately you
got the hospital there you can refer you
know when to refer and you gotta you got
a great team behind you but what was
great Shockers you have
all the corpsman and the corpsman you
were embedded with and the ability to
teach and train and work alongside with
just such great professionals
in Navy corpsman was unbelievable and
and something I'll never forget and we
did all these training things and go out
and camp and do simulated
blast wounds and simulated heart attacks
and train train drill drill drill it's
the same thing you know Team guys are
doing same team we're doing to prepare
our craft and for the next emergency
so where are you when 9 11 happens so
I'm in residency and we're at Balboa and
9 11. so you're back from Japan in
Balboa back at residency at Bobo yes
what are your thoughts when this happens
my brother called me he's like turn the
TV on I was like if he's active duty
he's 18 pilot he's getting ready to get
ship you know spinning up a carrier
right away and he had a lot of activity
over there
um
so saw the TV you're sort of protected
during this residency time although
there's been precedent and other
significant conflicts in the past
Vietnam Korea otherwise there they've
pulled people out of residency to go
assist the war effort and so that was
always on the table they wanted us to
finish residency first so of course
there was the initial flurry
we didn't actually see after you got
through the 911 and all the lockdown and
all the stuff and you know everything
sort of does sort of settles it wasn't
that busy until a couple years later and
that's when things started really
ramping up for us at Balboa so so you're
here in Balboa in like
2004 2005. this is when we're in Iraq
this is when the Marines are because
you're seeing almost all Marines I'm
assuming for these wounds yeah for sure
because the Army would go to they'd come
home to different to Army hospitals but
Marines are going to come to the Navy
hospitals yeah it was interesting this
is when the Medevac system was it was
there but you know to my knowledge and I
don't want to speak out of turn it was
it hadn't been turned on now but it had
to get refined and how do you get
someone back from Afghanistan to North
Island to Miramar as quick as possible
as safely as possible and get them to
the higher Echelon care after they're
stabilized in theater and that that was
you know imagine a massive amount of
work and try service collaboration to
make that happen and a massive team
effort which
really the innovations that came out of
this to transport injured
men and women from overseas that were
service membered and injured what was
amazing and the the innovations that
came out of that such as the Hot Pocket
a to keep you warm when you lose blood
guess what you get hypothermic and so
you want to be able to keep their heat
up keep them
normal thermic as they say maybe a
little bit warmer and so really cool Hot
Pocket design and so patients are
treating these things called Hot Pockets
and that came out of it a better wound
vacuum a wound vacuum you were able to
put on blast wounds right away was
really fine-tuned and innovated during
this conflict I can't even tell you how
many wound vacuums we would change out
every day every night because we would
know at Balboa when patients were coming
in approximately how many were coming in
what your call night looked like so you
talk about those Duty hour things we had
some really long nights but it was a
team effort and we had some great uh
surgeons that worked with us Orthopedic
Trauma General trauma
um and but we didn't really have a
system when it first started and then we
got the C5 system which was a combat
casually cared system which really
helped leverage all of the all the
important aspects of caring for our
Wounded Warriors when they came back
so I imagine that when the kazavac birds
or Medevac birds are coming back these
are c-17s
they're coming back with a lot of
wounded Personnel on them so are you
getting like 20 people at a time 30
people at a time coming in there were
nights with that fortunately not every
night fortunately not every month but
there would be nights with I would say
the routine was during those years you
mentioned two three four a night so if
you were on call you were heading it up
you had your residents that were with
you and
and if we had more that we knew were
coming guess what you took all the night
before you volunteered and just took it
again and we just we just took care of
it but it was it was tough it was tough
to see these
um
young young men young women with you
know blown off limbs blown off legs
blown off ankles
X fix is on which are like these Erector
Sets you put on their legs and arms and
pelvis to stabilize their bones
stabilize their vessels and the
survivability developed by many of my
colleagues out there
and the Innovations they developed
increased dramatically during this
conflict and it really helped save lives
so we were seeing things back at our
tertiary Care Center at somewhere like
Balboa or Bethesda or Portsmouth or San
Antonio
where most of the kazavac was
that we weren't seeing in the past you
weren't necessarily seeing this stuff in
Vietnam and so you pull the war trauma
books from Vietnam there's a lot of
great stuff out there but people like
you know Captain Dana Covey and John
Webster and Mike mazarik and so these
other great trauma folks and leaders
that I worked with really helped develop
this system to
bring Orthopedics a little bit closer to
the fight so they can get stabilized and
then have its super fine-tuned slick
system when they got to some place like
Balboa
when you're
um looking at a wound let's say pre-911
you're at Balboa there's a car accident
you know a bad car accident
what's that wound compared to someone
that was in a Humvee armored Humvee on
Armored Humvee and they they hit hit a
roadside bomb they hit an IED
what's the difference between those two
scenarios from a medical perspective
yeah that's a really important question
and as you alluded earlier the the stuff
we were taking care of motor vehicle
accidents broken femur a broken ankle uh
falling from a first story window I mean
there was certainly some pretty bad
injuries we saw and and you're going 50
60 70 miles an hour but what you weren't
accounting for with the IED blast wounds
was everything else that went into it
the the magnitude the basic just shock
the awe that went into it the materials
that would go into these IEDs the stuff
we were pulling out of
uh these Wounded Warriors bodies was it
was beyond disheartening to be honest
with you
um
safety pins
cut up knives
coat hangers metal cut into a gazillion
different pieces and sharpened and it
just I we kept a little
clasp bowl or in our offices of
stuff we had kind of taken out and
sterilized to remind us
you know what was
what was some of these folks had gone
through and and
and and lived through a lot of them and
some that that didn't it was really
disheartening
how
what is it like when you're living where
did you live in San Diego we lived we
lived in lived in Coronado so you live
in Coronado probably one of the most
beautiful
uh picturesque places in the world to
live
you turn on the TV you see that there's
a war going on but you walk outside and
it's 70 degrees and sunny you get in
your car you drive to Balboa and you see
these these Wounded Warriors that are
just devastated by these wounds and
you're doing that day in Day Out
what what is what is that like from a
I don't want to say a psychological
perspective because I don't want to get
too like crazy as if I'm a psychologist
but that has to be an interesting
Dynamic to be living in San Diego it's
75 degrees and sunny it's a beautiful
day you flip on the TV you see that the
push is going into Fallujah you see the
push is going into ramadi you see
talafar you you oh you see that this is
happening I mean I can only imagine when
you see the Marines going into Fallujah
in 2004 you're thinking okay we got we
got to be ready and then sure enough 24
48 hours later you're getting you start
to receive these Wounded Warriors what
is that what is that like when you think
back on that time period it had to be it
had to be
had to be very
um
almost like a surreal moment to to just
to watch something on TV
and then deal with these Wounded
Warriors
yeah no question Jocko the the ability
first of all the ability of my hats off
again to the Medevac system because that
has saved lives
and the ability to get these folks back
in 48 72 96 hours
and sometimes a stop in Bethesda
sometimes a stop in San Antonio but
the the military did a great job of
trying to bring these Wounded Warriors
back closer to their families back
closer to where they deployed from back
closer to Camp Pendleton
because they knew and we knew that the
the mental
strain on them their families and the
injuries
were extreme it was real and
I can say the same thing for many of my
colleagues at Balboa whether you're a
general surgeon Orthopedic Trauma
surgeon
I was Orthopedic Sports surgeon so we
did a lot of this stuff and a lot of the
reconstructions but the real you know
heroes or something Orthopedic Trauma
surgeons the general surgeons and that's
off that's off to them
Plastics the mental health providers all
of C5 the combat casualty care set up at
Balboa Did an amazing job but you know
there are nights I I personally at least
talk I'd get off call and be like ah you
know let's fix the fourth external
fixator I've put on the 10th wound VAC
we've done this and fixed the stump of
the leg just above the knee and they
have no elbow and
you're putting these wound vacs and
xfixes on and
it's the the flesh the burning flesh the
hearing the helicopter these things that
you know we all kind of go through it's
became a little PTSD like in a way now
unfortunately he mentioned Coronado one
of the things that my personal
strategies was
when I went over the bridge from Balboa
San Diego to Coronado I tried to use
that as a decompress time the
the time over the bridge the time there
to go back to my family to decompress
because
there were some there were some tough
days in the medical team it was caring
for these
Heroes
and your your family at this point
consisted of how many kids did you have
your wife and wife and uh two at the
time no four so four soon after and they
were all you know of course very young
and living in Coronado and
you know really great setup and great
you know friends and Military friends
and pilots and all my friends are Naval
Academy for example they're pilots and
doing helicopters or jets or on ships or
subs or what have you or paos or all
these certain things on top and not not
to mention all the seals that you know
about 20 25 a year that the Naval
Academy put out based on uh based on
billets each year so it was really great
to have that Network also for my wife
and my family and you know for all of us
to have and just just lean on
did you ever feel like you wanted to
yell at everyone that there's a war
going on
I I I I did I
but I know so many had lived through it
and to be honest so much so many did way
way more than I ever did and so
I was just trying to you know put my put
my hat on of
let's do whatever I can do to help out
these Wounded Warriors because
the usual thing when I would go to their
bedside and talk and meet them whether
it was in the emergency room or C5 or
talking about reconstructing their knee
or their shoulder
doc when can I get back when can I go in
the fight again when can I join my unit
it was the most amazing thing to me the
Esprit of core
the leadership exhibited out there to
put that together and realize that it's
like you want to go back to that
and that was almost always the first
question it was amazing
yeah I know that I got home from my last
deployment and I just was probably been
home for less than a day and was going
to grab something to eat with my wife
and I'm just walking down the street in
OB in Ocean Beach and I just remember
looking and there was clearly for no one
on this street there was no war going on
there was no war going on they were
doing what they were doing and I
remember thinking to myself
I kind of I was like thinking I should
just tell all these people hey you know
there's a there's a freaking war going
on right now and you should be
appreciative of the fact that you're
standing in line to get an ice cream
and then I remember thinking you know
what that's my job and
that's the way it is and I just kind of
like accepted the fact that
these people are never going to think
about it they're never going to think
about it that three miles away in Balboa
there's a young Marine that's struggling
to stay alive or struggling to keep his
leg and or he's going to lose his leg or
lose his arm or whatever and they can
just just kind of ignore it it's um
it's it's very it's it's a dichotomy
inside this country that's can be if you
if you let it make you angry it can
definitely make you angry if you let it
get to you it can definitely get to you
but if you look at it
you know I I remember one time uh well
one of my kids you know told me that the
Wi-Fi in their bedroom wasn't strong
enough you know
and I thought to myself well I guess I'm
doing a decent job as a dad if the
biggest struggle you have is that the
Wi-Fi and your room you only have four
bars right
and you know I thought and then I said
to myself you know as these kids get
older you know I'm going to make sure
that they understand that there's a lot
more important things and there's people
that there's people in the world that
have uh a lot less
a lot a lot bigger things to worry about
than you do so I kind of got that
feeling too for the country like okay
you know they're they're going to stand
in line they're going to get ice cream
and it would be nice if they recognized
and I think that's one of the one of the
reasons that I do this podcast is just
so people can hear from
people that have served people that have
sacrificed or hear stories of people
that have served to people that have
sacrificed and that's why I mean you
know even as I'm sitting here thinking
about you
you're you're in Coronado like I said
one of the most picturesque places in
the world you got your family your
family's doing what families do right
they're playing their Sports and they're
hanging out they're going to the beach
and yet every day you've got to go in
and and
put these broken guys back together
again and there's that constant daily
reminder of of what's going on in the
world
and how just
how totally different these these worlds
can be and it's it's really important
for people to pay attention to that and
understand that that there's a lot of
suffering going on and even though maybe
your little bubble of the world is is is
happy just pay attention the fact that
there's a lot of suffering going on out
there
when did you start working with nsw
yeah so that uh actually started about
2003-ish I would say 2002 three uh one
of my mentors getting Mike Langley was
down and and working with nsw from an
orthopedic standpoint and doing doing
doing some stuff with them and and being
available
and he actually uh you know left Balboa
and so
I was in Coronado I said well do you
want to you want to go and I said raise
my hand and I'm like sure what do we do
you know he's like I don't know anything
at this point about the the training
room or you know what the medical setup
was you know we're still dealing with
all the stuff and the blast wounds we we
just talked about and but we had this
concept which was
bring our skill set closer to the fleet
and that was San Diego y we had smart
clinics in Miramar and uh down to 32nd
Street a smart Clinic being a sports
medicine and rehabilitation type of
Clinic because why a lot of the injuries
we see were musculoskeletal in the
military it's an on-ending pipeline of
18 19 20 year olds coming to the
military and they're jacking themselves
up playing basketball or whether they're
deployed and so
there's a lot of musculoskeletal burden
in in the military and I felt it was a
really
important in sort of many of my
colleagues that we brought and made it
easier like go to Balboa get a parking
spot deal with a parking situation up
there and get an appointment and you
know before you know it you're gone from
the command for six hours coming from a
guy in the teams going to Balboa for
anything was the worst nightmare ever
like I'd rather just suffer I'd rather
just sit over here and Limp around let
it just be broken then have to go to
Balboa which is going to take five hours
yeah but that's I mean that's a fair
assessment job going we didn't you know
that wasn't
our our goal was always to serve the
fleet the best and this was on top of
doing the smart clinics and taking care
of the Marines because you know they
were getting banged up taking care of
you know all the men and women not only
Marine Corps but in the Navy down 32nd
Street out at Point Loman bringing us to
see Clinic alongside our Incredible
family practice sports medicine
colleagues or physical therapists or
athletic trainers all of this was really
starting to be born here in a nice way
in San Diego let's face it we have so
many great commands here we do
everything here in San Diego from the
Navy and so we wanted to be able to
deliver that make it easy take Jocko's
six-hour trip to Balboa which he would
never come and then then he'd really rip
his biceps and we'd have to fix it but
it would be
something that you know I was certainly
passionate about and so this was another
one of our things where we delivered it
to the fleet but me being in Coronado I
would often you know put my bike on get
that helmet on my bike so I can get on
base and my beach cruiser around San
Diego and uh
went and met uh met Jason and people
like Mark rogo and and others there and
we we had a great had a great situation
it was amazing and my hat's off to
people like Jason where I don't know
Jocko you were in the closet where he
started then you went to the trailer and
they said the closet I mean this is like
where the rehab athletic training
facility you know the training room was
yeah somebody in nsw and I wish I knew
who it was it's it's weird when when
something gets developed in nsw and I've
been using the term nsw that's Naval
special Warfare that encompasses all of
the Special Operations elements within
the within the U.S Navy and so when
something happens in nsw
I can tell you right now a human being
had to take that thing and force it to
happen and it took them years to get a
foothold whoever and I don't know who it
is maybe you do whoever decided all
right we're gonna do some kind of a
human performance we're gonna get
athletic trainers in here we're gonna
get the guys healed up we're gonna do
injury prevention with them
whoever started that probably had to
work for two and a half years and
finally were able to hire one guy and
put him in this you know little tiny
maintenance closet in the back of a
command somewhere
that's how things start and so whoever
that was thank you and it was Jason the
first guy that got hired
he was one of the earliest for sure so
we he got extracted a Major League
Baseball unfortunately just just a great
individual and he's still with the teams
I still I still text Jason if I get
dinged up I text him like Hey bro hear
my rolled my ankle pretty swollen here's
a picture what should I do you know I
still do that for this day with Jason
and he still responds and says hey if
you need me to come out look at it like
that guy cares about his patience to a
degree that's just incredible and he's
done that for all of like every guy that
would get injured could get surgery get
banged up he was just there committed to
him all the time and then and then the
rest of the team followed suit that's
what you got we got this incredible
group together that would provide this
amazing service and they also had a
different
you know you go to a regular doctor
and the regular doctor might think oh
you got hurt cool we'll get you as much
time off as we can
but the Seal attitude is I got hurt and
I want to get back in the game tonight
like I gotta I want to go tonight oh you
can't go tonight tomorrow I want to get
back in the game so Jason and the rest
of the team understood that their
mission and their goal and our goal was
to get back to work and that's a lot
different than
preserving you know I'm going to be per
in perfect shape and everything's gonna
be hunky-dory I mean it's not going to
be that way if you're in the SEAL Teams
just like in in MMA fighting you don't
get to go into a fight 100 you don't get
to do like you're gonna be injured
you're gonna be sore you're going to
have a a bruised rib you're going to
have a tweaked neck your shoulder's
gonna be sore that's the way it's going
to be and you still got to go out there
and fight and I think Jason and the rest
of the team you guys realized all right
we need to make sure these guys can get
the job done but we can't they're
they're not going to allow themselves to
be babied and coddled
no question and uh you you talk about
the classic conundrum and this is this
is what we knew and this is what we were
working on and this was not all my baby
or even a small fraction of it but you
know a great team and I remember us
going out after work one day I got a
call hey meet us at mcps in a bar in
Coronado and
we sat down and said what does this look
like and to your point two and a half
three years later this is what it looks
like and and so that was the first thing
we we sort of penciled out and you know
I was just one small Cog in the Wheel
from some of the musculoskeletal side
but we had so many other you know great
people from Jason Mark rogo and uh
Vinnie and many others
parsley yeah I mean there's so many
there's so many I'm forgetting and I
apologize if I do but the Tactical
athlete program got born it was a tap
program and that's you know now it's on
to the next iteration which I I hope we
can talk about because that's really now
I think the future of taking care of our
military members our most important
commodity
the human element at the best level and
so
we literally napkins sketch this things
out what components what have you seen
what do you talk to colleagues that have
done pro sports teams taken care of
the Rams and all these other
organizations and how can we affect this
for the teams to make a guy like Jocko
who does not want to go to Medical can't
stand it but actually wants to come in
and get some Wellness get some injury
prevention so you can go out and operate
and do your job better that was our goal
and literally no one would come in and
see us but
over time the switch has flipped and now
it's a really impressive program and
that's what's going on down there so the
Tactical athlete program that you guys
sketched out that was focused on
athletic trainers like the the Sleep
people they started looking at hormones
they started looking at everything to
try and get the guys up to speed and I
saw it grow like you said from Jason and
it just escalated escalated escalated to
we had a good a freaking world class the
other interesting thing was I remember
talking I think this guy was a person
that worked at buds but it's a it's a
similar thing and he'd come from some
professional sports team I think the NFL
and he had said you know when I was in
the NFL
every six months I'd see one uh patella
femoral syndrome which is you know a
problem that you get with your knee he
says here I saw nine yesterday like the
amount of injuries that guys get is
crazy and so you you guys in this
department got so much experience
working on the shoulders working on the
knees working on the lower back working
on the elbows working on the wrists
working on the neck like the guys are
just dinged up to a point that and you
know people talk about the NFL how long
what's the average NFL uh guy plays what
like six years is like the average three
3.8 3.8 something yeah senior position
you're getting dinged up well the seals
we most guys stay in look look some guys
get out at six years or whatever most
guys stay in most guys do 20 years at
least and they're they're doing
deployment after deployment after work
up after work up after deployment after
so these guys are getting dinged up and
yet they still want to play that game
they still want to get in there and so
you guys put this together
what were some of the key components
that you would say for for because this
is what you know so many people that
listen to this podcast they they wanna
they wanna perform better they want that
longevity they want to be they want to
optimize what they're doing what are
some of the things that you saw that
helped guys out
yeah well I think you mentioned a lot of
it and and the we broke it down in a you
know kind of big buckets where you sort
of how do we optimize
physical Readiness if yes big Navy big
military what is it all about from the
medical side for carrying an act of Duty
it's all about readiness your people
ready can they go are they ready to go
it's almost just like being in a head
team position for the NFL can can they
go can you are they ready
So Physical mental
and then uh more of a cognitive type of
thing with sleep and other things uh
baked in there nutrition was a big one
but really trying to organize the
elements of all of this into a program
that made sense and a program that you
and your colleagues would buy into we
didn't want to set up a you know brick
and mortar facility without
you want to go and be a part of it so we
had to have the right mindset or the
right culture because that really wasn't
in there you went to Medical prevention
was going to write you a chip and you're
getting four months of limb do in your
biceps operated on and you're out for a
while you know and that's that's not
going to happen unacceptable no so I'd
sound exciting it's not gonna happen I
can tell you it didn't even matter what
I you know what what I sort of
wrote you know fixing PEX and this and
that and shoulders and knees like
where's uh where's Master Chief so and
so oh well uh sir he's deployed but he's
only four weeks out of his AC joint
shoulder massive reconstruction yeah I
know sir but he had to go yeah yeah he
just had to go I'm like okay let's see
him when he gets back unfortunately I I
guess my point is you and your
colleagues Jago tested out the the
strength of what we did the strength of
our repairs we're always testing things
in Orthopedics back to my engineering
days of what is this strong enough is
this going to hold Echo Charles biceps
together is it going to be strong enough
is it going to hold Master Chief
so-and-so's AC joint together right and
because they're going to go early I
can't necessarily control that the
command has ultimate Authority I can
make we make recommendations from
medical to the command you get limited
Duty and all this kind of stuff but
it's amazing to me how you and your
colleagues not only you know tested them
but also kind of took care of some of my
technical inadequacies my colleagues
technical inadequacies because you just
rehabbed so well and with this tap
program which is now potiff and we can
talk about that in a minute but
it's really helped
take care of our Warriors at the highest
level yeah I think a huge part of it was
once we understood that you understood
we trusted you guys because if I went to
Balboa in whatever 1996 and said hey my
my neck hurts my shoulder hurts my back
hurts they're going to put us on the
protocol of okay well you need six
months off and you need this and that
and we realized
that you realized that we wanted to get
back to work and so when you told us
listen when Jason would look at me and
say Jocko you cannot do pull-ups for
three weeks you cannot do pillows for
three weeks he he like look at me and
Nod his head and say nod your head and
say I understand Jacqueline I understand
Jason no Pull-Ups for three weeks
because I had bursitis in my arm right
or whatever the case may be
there was a level of trust that we
developed with you guys that when you
told us to do something we understood
that that you meant it and it was right
and also to your point when you told us
hey here's the here's the rehab
exercises that you need to do and if
you're going to do the desert or you're
going to jungle warfare or whatever
you're going to do right now you can go
but you gotta do these rehab exercises
we would do them so we had a very good
uh mutually supporting relationship
where you were telling us what to do we
trusted that you were gonna allow us to
do as much as we possibly could but that
was also a limit
and hey you can't do this thing but no I
really really don't know you can't do
this thing okay we trusted you guys and
that that's what I think made the
program so effective and makes it so
effective to this day just this
incredible level of trust between both
sides
Jocko you nailed it and I think it was
incumbent upon my colleagues someone
like me to be able to to earn that trust
but I I have a saying everyone around
you has someone to teach you so I'm
sorry everyone around you has something
to teach you it's up to you to listen
and learn and I learned more from my
physical therapy colleagues my athletic
therapy athletic trainers Physical
Therapy nutrition parsley stuff was
amazing with all the sleep and
hormonal looks and I it was it was
really great to put this together in its
infancy and now it's you know just in a
much much better space and we we even
started but that's that's what started
the culture shift for people like you
and your colleagues to get better to
work more on injury prevention and
actually not View Medical as something
like we're gonna we're gonna take you
out of the fight our goal is to get you
back as soon as possible as strong as
you can
efficiently and safely yeah and there
was another element of trust and that
was
if I showed up to Medical there was
something wrong like like Jason knew if
I walked in there it wasn't like oh I
had a little Ding and maybe I was being
a whiner no if I showed up there there
was something that me I needed help I'm
not coming in there to to to miss work
I'm not coming there because I want to
get a limited Duty uh from you guys
no if a seal shows up to Medical there's
something wrong with them and they need
help you don't need to screen like well
are you sure this no no no we're there
because we're injured that's what's
going on so that that's also a very good
place to start is that we're not looking
for a way out we're looking for a way in
and and there's plenty of places in the
there's plenty of places in the military
and in the world where what they're
looking for is a way out like I want to
get limited Duty I don't want to have to
work right the seals are not doing that
we want to work right that's why we're
in there fix us and get me back in the
game right we do it we deal with uh you
know plenty of injured folks that you
know just may or may not want to go back
to work it's hard to dissect that out
there was absolutely no question down in
Coronado what you all want to do the
other thing is I I wanted to do is I
wanted to learn more and again back to
that learning thing and so
I went up to a lot of the uh you know
beginning of Hell weeks the the
breakouts and I got they're probably you
had traded like Roger get out of there a
million tons of brass there you're gonna
slip it's hot it's like I'm like what
I'm doing and but it was really good to
see you know I'll just break out but
going out to the desert going out to the
island with you guys being doing stuff
with you and watching and learning was
absolutely invaluable because I could
see what the stresses were going through
the shoulder the knee the mind the body
and that that helped us immensely
understand the the reports that they
came back with
I remember you guys put some kind of
monitors on guys like heart rate
monitors movement monitors and the guys
came back from our desert training
and it was like everyone was beside
themselves in terms of the output the
movement the stress level the heart rate
it was all off the charts it was like
they competed in you know world-class
competition uh triathlons with mixed in
with the decathlon you know it's like
strength endurance mental stress it was
all off the charts it's crazy when you
distilled down some of these numbers and
that's where it really started
the data movements once we got the nuts
and bolts in place we had some really
good people that we brought in to help
us with the data and analytics again all
about to help you perform better but you
start looking at some of these numbers
and it's like
you can go in the Tour de France
tomorrow like the the output the Watts
the climbs that I it's crazy numbers and
heart rates in the 30s and 40s and blood
pressures that
heart rate variability and all these
things we start to look at in terms of
how you recover how you perform
fine-tuned machines it's really good and
so we had to be we had to be even better
we had to find ways to be at our top
game because we're already dealing with
a pretty finely tuned human how do we
tune that person up even more especially
you know as you said you get on with
sixth tenth year 15th year in the teams
there's nothing more than we want to do
to than to protect that human capital
so then how did this program roll into
the uh the PFF the protection of family
of the protection of force family yeah
so so potiff and uh you know I'm gonna
probably get this all wrong but this it
finally got enough legs through people
like Captain Tom chaby Admiral mcraven
who you know extremely well and worked
with chibi and and others even Admiral
Eric Olsen and saw the utility I think
of what this program uh was about people
like Master Chief Glenn Mercer
others that it really started to look
holistically you know it's strength
nutrition conditioning sleep mental
health Wellness how to train diet Etc
learning how to take care of the body
and these little injuries that would
really keep
The Operators out of the more severe
stuff and so
that's I think really how potiff got
born and you know JB did an incredible
job of helping Shepherd this through
into your point it took a while it took
a lot of time and and in fact when you
when you look at the family side there
was all the operational dollars are for
active duty seals and direct active duty
seal but potiff is Preservation of the
force and family because
they knew that it was important to also
take care of your family while you were
gone and it was really critical to that
but from a funding standpoint that
hadn't been set up through Congress and
so you can put family in there but
there's no dollars it ain't going to
happen so that that took a little bit of
time but then the family became a really
important piece to holistically allow
the operator to be at their best and
there's a bunch of elements of potiff
which we can talk about but they're
they're really
basically the the essence of of what was
started with tap but is now just so to
the next level and I want to
congratulate you know everyone who's
just done an amazing job with this
program
yeah uh I think Chevy was like a
national level Mogul skier he was and he
and his both his knees were a nylon this
is before he joined the Navy so he had
to go through buds with just annihilated
knees and that's not uncommon it's not
uncommon for guys that obviously guys
are going in the SEAL Teams they were in
sports growing up and they already come
with pre-existing issues which I was
lucky enough I was like you know young
and just
healed I mean I was just good warrior
blood yeah Wolverine blood get some but
a lot of guys show up with already
pre-existing injuries that's a problem
so so this thing with the with the
protection of the force and family so
now all of a sudden we can bring the
wife in to she's getting knee surgery
we're going to help her heal up there's
that type of thing right
yeah that's exactly right is
you want to integrate you know the the
families into the units integrate them
the installations the communities
uh there's a concept with potiff to
build not just Brazilian operators but
resilient families and that was
something that would be able to
withstand the the op Tempo that was just
massive for you all and you were in and
out all the time and you know to the
point where your adrenal axis when you
came back thanks to parsley and others
doing just you know magician level work
to be able to help us discern that and
put that together and really take the
whole program to the next level and
lastly I think setting up a connection
with the families again this is you know
way over my skis here not my not my
expertise my ski tips here's not my
expertise but
understanding the whole thing and being
conversant about it and sort of my my
role down there to understand and be a
part of it my role down in Coronado was
to to have the knowledge so that we
could talk about it when an operator
came in and said hey how's your family
how you doing how's everything going
like
so and so may not ask about that but you
know as doc I can get away with that and
I knew that and I knew that you would do
better
we've got a great story one of my team
guys that operated on and you know this
is a credit to the whole program but you
know it's
I told you how well you already have and
fix the shoulder between the labrum tear
dislocated how long have you been
dislocating your shoulder I don't know
three years okay you've been dealing
with the hell how many times you've
dislocated 125 on a lost count 500 times
always literally like hundreds of times
you're like
the amount of uh resiliency you know
that that the operators demonstrate
never cease to amaze me it was it was
off the chart and this is a very typical
story well I just lived with it I had to
deploy I had to do my job I had to go be
there I had to be there for my team my
platoon my whatever I'm like
I get it but he's like listen this is
the last right I can't it's just coming
out too much it comes out when I look
the wrong way it comes out in my sleep
it comes out I'm like I gotta get it
fixed
you fix a shoulder that would do a great
job you know high five and classic out
of the or whatever you do and we get out
of the or and you know all of a sudden I
get a call from coronados you know four
five six weeks like ah man he's just not
making progress really stiff it's not
working out right senior Chiefs so and
so and I'm like oh man this is this is a
bummer um you should be doing better
okay look I'll be down tomorrow you know
come in the training room and see you
see with the Jason and like what is
going on here and
again and again and again we just kept
working we kept doing the therapy doing
all the right things it wasn't from lack
of trying from lack of being there for
lack of doing the right exercises
and then I I talked to parsley and I'm
like dude Percy what's going on any
ideas about this guy you know we're just
having a little bit of trouble you know
so we would talk about you guys behind
your back and doctor at a doctor you
know he could because we're taking care
of you and
he's like let me let me run some stuff
so it does labs and basically there's a
bunch of labs and parsley's laughing you
know no tons of them 10 page report or
something crazy look at the thing
there's like
undetectable testosterone adrenal axis
is all jacked uh there's you know a
bunch of these other parameters and
thyroid hormone and all these other
things just completely way off for
someone who's 37 years old
so he's like let me look into this it's
like okay
three four weeks later parsley works as
magic
and his shoulders like
healed it's like your biceps It's Magic
it's just fixed and he's like
so the whole that really got a big
wake-up call for us if I with my hammer
and nail just focus on the shoulder
I'm gonna get it wrong I'm gonna get
wrong for my patients now I'm gonna get
it wrong for you and your colleagues and
so that's where we really have to take
this holistic approach
understand our patients and use the
resources and the team around you it's a
team and you need teamwork to be able to
execute this at the highest level how
complicated is this shoulder
when it's jacked up
there there was no lack of challenge
that you guys gave to me and my
teammates and colleagues at Balboa based
on how jacked up some of these shoulders
were you know injuries that were in your
30s that we don't see to 50 or 60 like
completely torn rotator cuff arthritis
in the shoulder off the chart well it
doesn't really hurt that much I have no
idea how this thing doesn't hurt it says
I can do whatever I want I can I can do
Jiu Jitsu I can be a sniper I can do all
these other things without any
difficulty and
it really amazed me the level of
injuries that some of your colleagues
would present with but really just
demonstrated toughness I think
resiliency and focus on on their job of
the mission and and they would only come
in if it was really bad that's at the
end of the day I figured out the
shoulder though as a joint like when
somebody injures it
can you get it back how close can you
get it back to being
good to go 100 percent yeah it's
interesting Jaco so we have a bunch of
Specialties in Orthopedics and you do
your five years of Orthopedic training
you get done a Balboa and then you can
do a fellowship not everyone does a
fellowship but a fellowship is generally
one extra year of training and you can
just do a foot and ankle Fellowship they
become kind of a foot and ankle surgeon
you can just do a hand wrist kind of
elbow fellowship and that's some pretty
complex stuff and the Hand wrist elbows
a lot of Bones a lot of tendons a lot of
ligaments I mean there's
books bigger than your bookshelf here
and just on hand surgery in Orthopedics
uh I do mostly shoulder knee Sports
surgery which is it usually goes
together sometimes we add hip surgery or
hip Scopes into that as well then we
also have joint replacement surgeons
that just really focus on taking care of
arthritis so that usually the hip and
knee we have people that just do spine
surgery and neck and back and lower back
surgery and so
with me and in their shoulder knee I
really like the shoulder again back to
my engineering mind because it is a
little bit of a complex joint but every
every specialty in Orthopedic sort of
has their their Niche their tough parts
that you treat and take care of but for
me the shoulder was just super
fascinating it's a joint that is quite
mobile it's designed to be very mobile
it's designed to be moved around it's
designed to be held in by a gazillion
different muscles around the shoulder
girdle from your back and your scapula
with a lot of complex interactions of
ligaments muscles and bones and so for
me the shoulder is was always something
I I wanted to study and was very
passionate about
when you open that thing up do you do
you know that do you like how many how
many shoulders have you opened up
like thousands thousands yeah so you
when you open that thing up it's just
it's you know exactly what's going on or
not you know exactly what you can figure
it out you're looking at like oh this is
a little high this thing's a little
rough this thing's a little ruptured
like that's what it looks like to you it
is yeah and but it's it's what we train
and what we train to do is no different
than what you did it's it's discipline
it's following a process it's
uh knowledge
um anatomic knowledge is surgical power
pathologic knowledge understand the MRIs
it's surgical power to be able to take
care of your shoulder or knee or
whatever injury
efficiently and safely and to make sure
that all the pathology is corrected
back to normal as good as possible it
might not be able to be perfectly
corrected but we try to get it back as
normal as possible we ought to trinkets
to be able to do that and implants and
other other things so it's a really it's
a really fun job not be able to put this
stuff to put it together like I said
back you know earlier in in the podcast
was I like using my hands and I like
being able to use that on patients that
to help them get better and get back to
get back to enjoying life and living
life are they or do you use robotics now
to do any of this stuff we do yeah it's
amazing it's an exploding field in in
terms of replacing the the hip the knee
the robots helping you really do it I do
some partial knee Replacements in which
we do Robotics and it really helps
understand the the exact angle and the
femur versus the tibia the knee and what
those angles are and how you how you
integrate that and put the right implant
in the right size of implant I mean we
have a gazillion modular combinations of
implants these days and the ability to
do you know what I call Precision
medicine Precision surgery and
understand your exact bony configuration
which is different than Echo Charles is
is really important to get to get the
right outcome we're still early there's
stuff out there that say robots might
not be better than a very well trained
human and you know we might see that in
your world but I I think we're getting
there what we do know is that just like
everything planning matters and we're
doing a lot of planning in the shoulder
and the shoulder world you know I would
do you know shoulder like yours Jocko I
would have on the computer and basically
almost be able to depend on what type of
surgery you're doing be able to do your
surgery ahead of time on the computer
manipulate things change implants do
this do that
and really execute the whole thing ahead
of time would that be based on the 3D
image of my actual shoulder and what's
in there for real that's correct yeah
absolutely your exact image your exact
MRI scan or CT scan
and we would know exactly every we'd
know how to tell my patient we know
every nook and cranny about your
shoulder way more than you want to know
I'm happy to show it to you here's what
we're going to do here's a plan this is
how we're going to execute it and this
is what we this is what we plan to do
the I want to jump ahead a little bit
just in comparison but you know you have
you end up working for the New England
Patriots you know with the NFL
that the interesting thing or the tough
thing is like you got a seal he's on
deployment he hurts his shoulder he's
not going to a doctor like he's gonna
he's gonna use that thing for the next
four months or five months or three
months until he gets home from
deployment
the pro athlete they're they're getting
the opportunity to like completely uh uh
baby that thing
that's now look I know if it's the Super
Bowl or a playoff game you're gonna get
that guy in that game right
no one misses the Super Bowl that's the
way it's going
I mean unless you're I mean unless you
had surgery right no one listens you're
going to be in the game you're in the
game yeah so there are some similarities
from that perspective that you're gonna
get this guy to play that next game
yeah they do it's uh it's interesting
when I went to the when it went to the
NFL and
and Belichick
Robert Kraft Jonathan Craft interviewed
me to for the job and I really didn't
want the job per se I was like okay well
you know I got enough going on I moved
to Mass General I just moved my whole
family across country out of
I'll talk about culture show I got a
Coronado to Boston area and it's
hot and humid again and it's like what
do we what do we just do here
um
but it's great Boston's a great town uh
the crafts are incredible human beings
Belichick is is a great leader he's very
disciplined he's very organized and
convinced he has a photographic memory
he's brilliant
and what they were really interested in
was what what we had built with the SEAL
Teams what we had done as a team there
and how we had worked together and
and we they had a number of the elements
in in this team and a lot of the NFL
teams and other pro teams baseball
hockey you name it soccer had this stuff
but it was it was still a little bit
early and
we we helped integrate quite a bit and
augment their program with a lot of the
things we had
what I call battle tested in the SEAL
Teams and what wearables
like if Jocko's gonna have a wearable
it's going to work and otherwise he
ain't wearing it and so I know those
wearables that the team guys would use
and so okay well if
the player wants to use it and they have
to agree to it there's all kinds of
rules with the NFL PA The Players
Association and things you can and can't
do
in terms of mandating and testing and
use of wearables and stuff like that so
I
but at the end of the day I wanted to
deliver Precision medicine to every
player so just like with the teams they
could optimize themselves and perform it
at the best give them the information
here's where you're at here's where your
sleep's at here's where your nutrition's
at here's a 20-page lab report we're
going to sit down with our super smart
nutritionist Ted and you know our head
athletic trainer Jim Whalen and you're
going to sit down and work through this
stuff and truly understand how to
optimize your body oh did you even know
you had a lactose
intolerance uh no but I well we're going
to help you with that and three to six
weeks later the player feels immensely
better just super simple things that
we're able to identify
and bring with a lot of nutrition a lot
of sleep hygiene wearable technology
tracking sensors in in performance and
in play
all of this was stuff we had already
done with the teams and the SEAL Teams
had his and so bringing that to you know
bringing out the NFL and the Patriots
was was really really pretty cool again
they had a lot of it it was just kind of
fine-tuning augmenting but really saying
look if this is going to work in a seal
there's a good chance this might work in
the NFL player and that's that stood
pretty well and and you know just to
back up Belichick was you know down in
Annapolis you know Naval Academy didn't
go there for for college but you know
knew it quite well so we had a very good
relationship being you know it's huge
support for the Navy and you know craft
certainly wonderful wonderful humans
that are also you know hugely supportive
of the military and you know in fact
they would ask me routinely because they
would always recognize a service member
and I brought
and recommended a few people I had
operated on you know including a marine
who had not just one purple heart but
two purple hearts when he was about
ready to get you know tossed out of the
tossed out of the military able to tune
up his knee operate on it fix it but he
was recognizing one of the Patriots
games so just trying trying to give back
and give back to the community I think
is what it was all about
what's the uh comparison between an NFL
player and a t and a seal
there's they're similar are we um
the drive to get better the drive to
optimize yourself the drive to do the
job all of that's there and the
resiliency the mental toughness the
um if you're getting at the top you know
any level at all not just the top level
you're doing things right and it's it's
a similar mindset at the professional
athlete level you're you're you're doing
things that most other people aren't
when I see the like shows about Tom
Brady
is there anyone more focused on that
than that guy on like his performance
Tommy's the best and he's focused and
Incredibly well on
winning Super Bowl he that's every year
that's what he wants to do and he's he's
the best and a a great person a great
leader
um
cares a ton I I learned a lot from Tommy
it seems like there's nothing else in
his head besides this game
that's what I'm doing
yeah I mean it's it's Uber focused it's
amazing and you know but but all these
guys and you know when he's thrown to
whoever you know Gronk Edelman you name
it they it's that same it's that same
Uber focused mindset there's a little
bit of just almost
it depends how you every player
internalizes or doesn't internalize it
but it's it's you're amped I mean you're
ready to go on the mission you're ready
to go like it's go time and
it's it's really cool to see that that
comparison between you know the SEAL
Teams and the pro athletes like it's go
time and and you're ready yeah the weird
thing about the SEAL Teams is the game
is so varied you know the the missions
are so different and you got to be ready
to kind of do all of them and so you
don't get to just have this one singular
focus in your brain you've got to have
you just can't you have to be able to do
a bunch of different things so it's a
little bit harder to prepare for you
can't just be a one trick pony I'm not
saying Tom Brady's a one-trick pony
that's not what I'm saying but I'm
saying he got to he got one game to play
you know he had to throw that damn ball
right that's what he had to do and you
know in the SEAL Teams You Gotta Throw
the damn grenade but you've also gotta
climb the ladder you've also gotta shoot
the rifle you've also got to carry the
rucksack you've also got a buddy carry
your friend you've also got a low crawl
across the field you got all these
different things there's a lot of stuff
you're going to be generally prepared
for no offense Tom Brady respect
um you talked about Belichick's
leadership right how's that leadership
in the when you when you're the lead
surgeon leadership in in the medical
world what's that like
it's important you know you're the
you're the leader every day you're
leader of the the clinic the operating
room but you got an incredible cast
around you to help execute on the the
plan of the day and that's doing Clinic
taking super high-end care of your
patience going to the operating room uh
you know leading a a great environment
there and it can be a stressful
environment you can get into trouble you
can you know been there I can knock on
what Nick someone's vessel you know
bleeding and also the entire shoulder
wound you just talk about is now full of
red bright blood and you're like what do
you do next what's the next plan what do
you do how do you get out of this
that's a real deal because it doesn't
take long before the rest of the
vascular volume is depleted and then
things can happen really quickly so
having the
ability to
be level-headed to be cool to be calm to
follow the process to have
your plans set in place b c d and e down
the road in case things happen
to take a deep breath I was in the
operating room and I just talked about
that I had vessel and all of a sudden
that blood was in the wound and all of a
sudden it can't see anything through
this six inch incision because it's
literally full of about five cups of red
blood and you're like okay
what do you do you're good just like
anything direct pressure again put your
finger on up with a pad on a lap bag and
the pressure on it how do you handle
that how do you have that cool calm
collecting to be able to do that you
know you could really it could
decompensate really quickly but
I got to thank the Naval Academy the
constantly now mag the constantly
what are you gonna do it was always that
that you know help man believe me I'm
not perfect at it and I've had some
really great people that have taught me
how to do this but the first thing I did
okay get the direct pressure take
immediate care of it we're gonna be okay
we got a few seconds turn around
talk to the perioperative nurse talk to
the scrub technician say here's what we
got we got into a little bit of bleeding
we got direct pressure on it this is
what we're going to do can you please
get so and so can you please alert the
general vascular surgeon can you please
also get two units of red blood cells
from the anesthesiologist uh can you
please get this gel foam and thrombin
which is a special
clotting agent that you can put into the
wound
and then you get back to work but that
10 15 seconds is so valuable to be able
to reset the team
rather than just diving right in you got
10 15 seconds at least in our world you
went in about 15 seconds be able to just
take a step back
breathe and then get the process fully
defined
the discipline standard operating
procedures take a step back that's what
we're doing
exactly hey what do you think about
um
with going back to football again what
do you think about what's it look like
from the inside when they start talking
about the CDE and the brain trauma and
all that stuff what's the what's the
feeling inside that world right now
yeah it's it's the it's the real deal
and it's definitely
um not only conversation but to the
point where
uh there's a ton of research you know
for the medical side there's a ton of uh
NFL sponsored grants for all kinds of
concussion studies CTE how do we prevent
this how do we make it better and I can
tell you from I was there from 13 ish to
16.
in the NFL it's it's way better even now
in terms of what we have for
athletic trainer spotters we have two
neurologists on affiliate with the
league on the sideline and or
neurosurgeons we have brain health
experts we have
a
mindset that's there at least talking to
my colleagues that are in the league
full-time still is
brain health is super important and we
need to be able to make sure we're
taking care of the players at the
highest level and making the right
return to play decisions or not return
to play decisions and making that with
independent neurologic Consultants that
truly know neurology I was having to
make that call and believe me I'm not
the best person to make that call as a
worthy Excursion I I know enough of it
we do
we do these you know scat tests these we
just barely had these iPad things going
we'd do it on paper in the locker room
and you know do these basic uh verbal
three verbal questions that the players
would you know memorize and count from
sevens and you know what day is it and
where are you and they would all
memorize them they knew the whole thing
why because I don't need a jock I want
to play the NFL player wanted to play
they wanted they wanted to stay in the
game but they're also becoming the
player is also becoming much more
cognizant
of their their brain health too and and
they know when they know when
the self-policing is really important
and and the team policing is really
important and see I think that's the
biggest mindset in culture change we the
NFL is taking it super seriously I
applaud them for it and I congratulate
all the great research and science
that's going on with this and let's face
it the military can also is learning
along the side side and there's a lot of
DOD research out there obviously from
blast wounds that are way higher in
intensity and collaborating with the dod
among many other institutions and
government entities out there is going
to help us I think get this problem
nearly solved did you work at the Red
Sox or the Bruins when you were up there
yeah we did we did jock I wasn't the
head doc but was the assistant dog we
could cover I don't know eight or ten
games and share the 81 home games that
we had to cover we were in the playoffs
and maybe a week of spring training
um
and uh you know somewhere for the Bruins
doing 6 18s but I had a I had a great
team in in Boston that really did a good
job of taking care of the teams but I
mean I was just taking care of the
team's full-time job on top of being
orthopedic surgeon on top of uh running
the the sports Division and research
around a fellowship and training
everyone it was it was it was a lot I
didn't have any uh didn't have much solo
time if you will and was Johnny Kim up
with you at this time he was yeah so
what what an amazing individual that's
another time I remember so when he was
applying to become an officer
you and I sat on his board uh and re did
his officer interview board to write him
a recommendation to go and become an
officer at uh and I remember I he wanted
to become a doctor and I remember saying
you know I'm sitting in the room with
you and I read who the other person was
but I I'm sitting here saying I don't
know why you want to become a doctor I'd
never want to be a doctor I don't like
hospitals I don't like doctors I don't
like nurses I don't like medicine and
then I said but if if there was anybody
I wanted to take care of my kids it'd be
you Johnny and we gave him a strong the
best recommendation we possibly could
but uh did you remember him from that
time frame as well because he's a Corman
he's a medic yeah no he's I remember
Johnny extremely well and another one
was my partner Dan Solomon who was
probably there and you know I apologize
if we forget exactly he wasn't on that
board but certainly that was that was
very interesting yeah
you know Johnny Johnny went full board
but he would hang out with uh one of my
other sports colleagues Dan saw myself
talk to Balboa we published research
papers together we I'd come to the
operating room come to Clinic you know
just just like what had been done with
me you know he wanted to go into
medicine and I applaud him for it and he
had to go back and
it was GI Bill and go to like San Diego
State and take classes and do all these
other things and
what an incredible story with your
podcast with him and Incredibly proud of
he and what he's done and who he
represents because he also visited with
me in Boston because he was at Medical
he was a medical school at Harvard and
so he would come and kind of randomly
show up in my clinic which was right in
downtown Boston on Charles Ave and
pretty pretty cool spots he would show
up and it was a nice
it was it was it was really nice to see
him there to have the connection after
uh what he had done with the SEAL Teams
but then next level now NASA astronaut I
mean just amazing
that's Johnny and when you talk to him
he's still the same Johnny he still just
look you know you know do you need help
with anything what can I do like just
humble and awesome as always so so one
of the stories I told Johnny Jocko was
um
about
Balboa again because he was asking his
ass about the Patriots and everything
else I said listen
it was uh it was during our Super Bowl
run when the Patriots ended up beating
uh Seattle Seahawks in the Super Bowl
and and it was sometime in October
before that Super Bowl and Belichick
comes finds me he's like Professor doc
here's what we got
we're going to Green Bay
in November after Thanksgiving it's
gonna be cold I'm just telling you've
been in Green Bay for a game yes what's
going on a guy here's the deal what
we're going to do is we're going to go
to San Diego after Green Bay we're not
coming back to Boston we're gonna go to
San Diego's we're playing the Chargers
in San Diego you know still the stadium
here before the San Diego Chargers moved
up to LA
what can we do in San Diego
doc that is not the bleeping bleep in
Sea World not the zoo not that that's
what college teams do we're pro team
but what can we do in San Diego I need
like an afternoon diversion for these
guys
all 53 active players plus 10 on the
practice squad plus all the coaches I
mean it's like five buses worth of
people because every player gets their
own row basically it's I I said coach
let's go visit Balboa
let's go visit our Wounded Warriors
and so in
first week of December 2013 we had it
all set up with Balboa and
I don't know maybe it's been done before
but you know certainly some people have
called me and talked to me about it but
all 53 players all 10 practice squad all
coaches after practice that day at USD
University of San Diego in the mid late
morning
head over to Balboa for about two hours
and we had it set up so they knew sort
of what state the player was from
and so or what college they went to and
played football and so you went to
Wounded Warriors rooms as part of C5
where you were from that state so
there's at least some state to state
connection and
I was walking around and you know Brady
was kind of sequestered in one area of
of the courtyard and everyone was coming
in trying to get autographs and hang out
with him but the rest of the team
and you know Brady went out and saw it
on the other wood Warriors as well I
don't want to say he didn't do not do
anything he was super busy that in that
visit but the entire teams are all five
buses you know usually you get like
maybe you know three or four or five to
go visit you know
cancer or children's hospital or
something you know something really good
that the community gives back from the
NFL
but this was the entire organization
everyone and the reporters and
and standing there in the courtyard or
waiting to load the buses up these guys
are getting hungry because they uh you
know consume a lot and burn a lot of
calories obviously so we're getting
ready to go back to the hotel and um
Del Mar understanding of the racetrack
at one of the hotels up there and
I see like Vince Wilfork and Edelman and
you know some of these really respected
players and names just get on the bus
and tears are streaming down their face
and
it was a very
um
interesting almost emotional
uh when we went back to the hotel dinner
and asking you know John Edelman and
Vince and some of these other guys and
Gronk I was like
how was that and they're like dog it was
just incredibly moving I've got a
Wounded Warrior guy with
one arm
uh an elbow on the other side
no legs
telling me to go kick some ass on Sunday
and motivating me more than I was
motivating them
they were like I'm supposed to be coming
in motivating these guys
and it just was so it was so touching
and you never you never get praised From
Below you get it indirectly and he came
up and was just very thankful and it it
was very meaningful it meant something
yeah I can imagine that like I was
talking earlier about how there's a
disconnect you know the countries at War
and yet the most of the country's not at
War and here you introduce these guys
and showed what kind of sacrifices are
being made and uh you know these guys
are an even more extreme example you
know yeah I was talking about you living
in Coronado and that's a nice place to
live but these guys are you know
multi-millionaire people that play a
game with a ball for a living you get
paid millions of dollars to do it and
they see the sacrifices that are made by
these these young Warriors that you know
like you said quadruple amputee I mean
who's still telling people to get fired
up and hey go kick ass today that's just
that's the kind of thing where you they
they realize what kind of sacrifices are
being made for them to be able to do
their job and live their life it's I can
I can only imagine what it must have
felt like for them to see these to see
these young Wounded Warriors that's um
That's Heavy for sure yeah yeah it was
did you did you
as your
working this kind of stuff you know nsw
and and and
the NFL and stuff
I know you talk about a lot about data
and collecting data and then utilizing
data well tell me a little bit more
about that
yeah so I mean this this was really born
out of you know Coronado and
some smart people were doing there but
we had to we had to put it together we
you can collect all kinds of numbers and
data and how Jocko sleeps every night
and what your sleep score is and your
adrenal access and how your why balance
score is and force played analysis and
all these great things but
you got to be able to interpret it
because I mean I've already gave you
like a million data points just in one
day what are you gonna do with that so
we really started working hard on
interpreting the data and be able to
start really in its in in the infancy so
he's almost uh Ai and machine learning
artificial intelligence in a way and you
know super hot topic now but you know we
were way ahead of the curve in terms of
putting this stuff together and really
analyzing it in a statistical way
so that number one we could get the
operators the right resources we knew
where they the ROI was going to be we
knew what resources The Operators were
using and
we knew Precision medicine Jocko is
different than your master chief at
trade it much different body as you
described and much different
requirements and much different biceps
so we would look at that and and really
try to say okay this is now what a
specific type of person breacher or
sniper and what those differences are
and start looking at from even a job
standpoint so this was really unique
stuff back in the day to be able to help
a sniper do better upreach or do better
but they're not the same person for the
most part right and the
and we could help that person optimize
optimize their craft
when I went to the Patriots
I quickly learned you know little
although Belichick was was brilliant in
photographic memory he was not going to
learn medical speak so I had to learn
coach speak so just like you know like I
had to learn what a breacher did because
I saw it and went out and you went to
the desert and saw what you do is breach
her and I could understand it better
with the mechanics of that word what the
shoulder and what the knee was doing and
the hip and the back and the stresses
across the body
I I did the same thing in the NFL and I
wanted to be able to look at how to
discern the medical information we had
that was on our team and provide that
back in coach speak so it's pretty
basically you play Fantasy Football you
do football it's
uh catches it's yards it's a snap
percentage how many if you're a running
back and you do this many snaps usually
how is your snap percentage
for three Downs are you playing all
three of those Downs are they taking you
out because they're managing load or
because you got an injury or other
things and so that's where we really
started to dissect this down Jacob is
how do
the stats help a team understand their
team their position better like a slot
receiver like Edelman versus
Center or Lyman like Vince Wilfork two
totally different bodies totally
different person but different stats to
follow but sometimes they can have the
same knee injury so how do you interpret
that same knee injury that same ankle
sprain that same high ankle sprain the
low ankle sprain the knee sprain the
meniscus the hamstrings a really tough
problem how does that behave differently
for someone's on the offensive line or
someone was a slot receiver so it was a
quarterback someone who's a cornerback
so that's what we really started to
discern is really taking a
personalized but also
specific position approach to the data
so that I could deliver a bill and the
team better information take it with
once with it you know it's like me
saying okay Jocko you're not going on
the planet well it's too bad he already
left it's here's here's the information
but it actually really helped from
helping predict performance and now it's
now we're to the point where we're doing
this
on the outside of the NFL and doing a
bunch of predictability models as well
did you make a lot of money off of
fantasy football during this time period
so it's it's interesting I we have a
rule where you you cannot
um a bad new fantasy in fact my kids
don't want to be in a fancy really good
I mean eventually you know you know
what's going on you know what's good for
you know you know what's going on with
Kronk's knee you know it's I'm like
I can't and neither can I name my team
but speaking of Team you know for the
for the Patriots we had and we built it
up quite a bit but we had
almost
75 people they were just part of the
medical team many of those full-time
a lot part-time but you know I guess
it's taking care of the family it's just
like potiff you've got OB going you've
got a dermatologist you've got a dentist
you've got pediatricians you've got
family practice doc Sportsman I mean
you've got everything
and so it sort of falls under the head
team position purview plus the head
athletic trainer and I mentioned before
Jim Whalen you know the guy's incredible
to be able to organize this whole
medical system for the players and their
families it's really impressive how much
of a beast is Gronk like as a physical
human specimen he was that guy just a
mutant he's jockey's one of a kind it's
amazing I mean I've never seen anything
like it he is he is a mutant yeah it's
it's like they should call him this dude
right yeah just like let's reproduce
this dude and give put him make
thousands hundreds of thousands and put
them in the military Unstoppable
Unstoppable yeah that's that's probably
part of his name and he seems like such
a nice guy too he's the best Grog is the
best he's one of a kind he's just he's
amazing but yeah he is he is a beast you
did you do the work on him uh no took
care of him took care of him after yeah
when we start talking about recovering
from surgery like what's the biology
around that what's the best way when
people are recovering what do you got to
do
yeah so so it depends I mean say you
tear your ACL you know Terror ligament
of the knee
we need
to get that ligament to heal it's
reconstructed you gotta get that
ligament to heal so there's a biologic
healing response and then
also a physiologic response the
physiologic response is you know you're
working on every day you know in in the
gym working on your your squats your
hamstrings your core your uh all the
other muscle groups that we really work
on and try to get Super Creative in
terms of our exercises but we also have
to balance that with the biology because
you can go out right away at four to six
weeks after an ACL reconstruction but
guess what that ligament has not
undergone what we call ligamentization
or the ability to even heal into the
bone because that ligament seal bone to
bone the femur and the tibia that's
where the ACL connects and so
if you rush biology and by the way if we
could find a way to improve the
efficiency of biology and to get
people's muscles back we could really
make an impact on some of these longer
recoveries but we're looking at this
from a very holistic standpoint you know
and so that's why we want to optimize
our nutrition their sleep their recovery
time their musculoskeletal program the
core if you just while your quads are
too weak or quads are too weak after ACL
well that's just not it you need your
hamstring I need your core I need your
back I need your abdominal muscles lower
extremity your your calf your perineal
muscles we need everything that whole
kinetic chain as we say to function
better before you go back and that
that's why that's why I love this job is
you have you know the ability to not
only fix the knee but then help coach
that patient back to a successful
outcome
do you do Seth stone surgery on his knee
I did so that's amazing yeah he had a he
had a and she was still with us jockling
it was a great friend of yours and
I miss them and a great great individual
he had
very bad knee dislocation multi-leg knee
and we um with that sometimes we have to
do not just one surgery but two
surgeries because sometimes there's four
main ligaments in the knee the ACL the
PCL the MCL and the LCL it's all around
the knee on top of other structures your
meniscus your capsule your cartilage and
he dinged a number of them yeah and he
did it really he did it really uh well
that landing and so anyway we
reconstructed it in two surgeries staged
about six eight weeks apart but the
great news is he was able to
you know again do what I talked about
take take care of my Technical
inadequacies and Rehab Beyond and do do
an incredible job and get back to his
craft I was uh
went down he was doing rehab there in
the clinic and I went down and whatever
he was doing was hurting really bad
um like he's trying to bend it to a
certain angle right this is you know
you've got to make it to a certain angle
there was some kind of a device that was
measuring the angle that he was bending
his knee to for the first time and he's
pushing past to try and get a little bit
more
and he's
it's a machine that's doing it if I
remember correctly there's a literal
machine that's moving his leg for him am
I right that's right yeah so CPM passive
motion machine yeah yeah it puts you
through the paces so he's in that thing
and I come down and he's in absolute
agony which is making me laugh
hysterically so I'm standing next to it
I'm waiting for the machine to go and
push his leg again and I'm laughing and
I finally get out my phone and start
recording him as I'm laughing so now
he's in absolute agony
but he's also laughing because I'm
laughing at him so he's got this look on
his face of you know I'm gonna I'm an
absolute agony right now and this is
hilarious and uh but he has you know he
was able to heal up but it's a long it's
a long process yeah you're describing
exactly what you know that type of
injury he had and that's what we all
worry about is you know Orthopedic
Sports any surgeons is
stiffness lost emotion you can't get
your motion back guess what you don't
have the muscle Excursion your quad
doesn't work as well your hamstring
doesn't work as well so
I don't you don't care how much you work
it and how many leg press it but if you
don't get the joint Mobility back you
can't optimize your muscle groups and so
it's it's a really tricky balance we're
always trying to
get people back as efficiently and
quickly as we can but you know that
whatever he was doing in there worked
and I I appreciate him you know gritting
and bearing through it and love to see
that video but he's
that but to be able to do that that's
that's the only reason he was able to
get back and do his craft you've got to
do the PT correctly for sure yeah can't
blow it off
so as you're as you're I mean with all
the knowledge that you've got everything
you gained from the teams what kind of
daily protocol
are you doing to stay healthy to stay
fit like what do you do
yeah and Jocko I've always tried to be
good about this I mean I have to admit
even back in the day I almost got a
little burnt out from you know all the
rowing and the US national team kind of
training stuff that was in and out of
that circuit and you know so I wouldn't
if I saw an ERG I saw one here I was
like
PTSD is taking the shakes I'm like but
I've gone through that and so that was a
big that was a big thing but
um with our with our life sometimes
especially you know in healthcare and
I've taken care of a lot of colleagues
and there's you know there's a No
Greater honor than not only operating on
you know a Seal Team but also
other orthopedic surgery surgeon
colleagues or other professional medical
professional colleagues and I love you
know I love taking care of you know all
walks of life I mean we do a ton of pro
athletes to college to the other docs
but
I always find myself telling them and
it's really probably me telling myself
when I'm talking out loud is
look you've taken care of people your
entire life
you're now 58 you've got a bad Rotator
cuffed hair
I'm like listen take a little bit of
time take care of yourself first and
then everything else will follow and
you'll be able to take better care of
your patients and so I've tried to
follow more and more of that I wasn't
always the best at it to be honest
because we get so busy we're so busy
with our life we're also teaching we're
traveling we're teaching residents
taking care of our patients teaching
fellows it's it's a it's a busy life
it's extremely rewarding but
I you know I gotta tell you you've
helped inspire me among others to make
sure that I'm taking care of myself and
and I use that all the time and I think
about you a lot I take your supplements
I'd use the stuff I like it a lot
um they're all natural and you know it's
it's amazing stuff and
I I feel better on them but it's also
helping me do my routine better and my
most predictable time just like you just
like your watch at 4 30 is I'm up about
five five fifteen five thirty I go to
the gym I've also crafted my schedule so
that I can do that and push some start
times back by 15 20 minutes it's
unbelievable when you can do that and
and control your life because you got to
take care of yourself so that you can
take care of others yeah
so
you're um you were at you're at Boston
you were working with the with the
Patriots seems like this might be the
dream job of of a freaking doctor right
you got that Super Bowl team you got
Brady you got Gronk you got Belichick
you got this seems like a yeah pretty
much a dream job for someone in your
position
but you left I left
yeah what what Drew you away I know
statement to the question
so not only that Jocko but growing up in
New Hampshire I lived through some
pretty tough Red Sox years it's pretty
tough Patriots years yeah craft bought
the team and
you know they had one playoff appearance
before he bought the team and you've
seen you've seen what they've done
um it was my team I listened to it
watched it everything uh you know part
of it was and I think the biggest thing
was it was almost you know like the Navy
I did 16 and a half years of active duty
that another 10 years of Reserves
and I I felt number one like I was ready
for the next challenge but also I had
been gone a lot you know taking care of
a pro team and you know to my colleagues
that have done it much much longer than
I have we're still doing it or getting
ready to do it
whether it's college team we're taking
care of SEAL Teams or the Patriots or
who you name whatever team pro team out
there Olympic
it's it's a massive time commute I bet
if I added my hours up which I did
because that's General wanted me to keep
track how many hours I did the Patriots
it was actually 55 60 hours a week just
to the Patriots
not let alone my surgeries and clinic
and running the fellowship so that was
that like your day job at at Mass
General no my day job I was being an
orthopedic surgeon and being head of
Sports at Harvard Mass General that's
that was my day job that was a side gig
at 50 to 60 hours a week so there's your
answer I I needed you know it gets back
to your question about also taking care
of yourself I love the job believe me
but I have young young family I wanted
to be around I didn't want to go to
their games you know and
because they're like hey
um they loved it I mean they got 50 yard
line seeds I mean they've been to a
couple Super Bowls before the age of
they went to my first Super Bowl was age
45. they were at two Super Bowls before
they were 14. it was crazy and they're
there the whole week embedded with the
team I mean talk about an incredible
experience but you know it's tough when
they said hey are you going to Kansas
City uh this weekend are you coming to
my soccer game yeah so these are life
choices and I made a conscious life
choice to
you know take a pause from that life but
still continue to give back and that's
why we moved to Vail Colorado where we
take care of the ski team and a few
other teams I still I do some U.S rowing
team stuff but I really just you know
focused on
a family enjoying what's you know in
Vale and also a busy practice where we
take care of a lot of great you know
athletes and all walks of lives and
that's at the uh the Steadman Clinic
that's right jackass what's the deal
with the Stedman Clinic yeah it's a guy
named Richard Stedman who started
actually started in in Tahoe and he
actually just passed away this this past
year I mean a big memorial service for
him in June in in Vail and he really set
up an incredible Clinic that you know
the culture just resonates with me so
well why because
it's the motto is
just take great care of your patient and
really focus on that spend time with
them and truly try to do the best we get
we get tough cases there we get tough
situations patients with tough problems
and
um but we get all walks of life we get
pro athletes College athletes Olympic
athletes we're also one of the Olympic
um
that the main Olympic provider usopc
Provider from a musculoskeletal
standpoint so work closely with usopc so
it's really great to see
um just all walks of lives all kinds of
you know incredible incredible athletes
of all different disciplines and and
sports so I I love the job family we
love Veil it's you know it's like
Coronado in the mountains in a way
you're seeing you in the mountains it's
a beautiful but the weather's great and
we know you have winter and you know we
we take care of that you know advantage
of all all the seasons there and you
know still occasionally I'd come back to
San Diego and 72 in sunshine I know you
have a rough here
so how many hours a week do you work now
so now I'm probably 50 to 60 60ish it's
it's busy but it you know I was I was
well over I was well over 110 120 and if
you I mean I mean it's incredible and
you know the the my hat's off like the
athletic trainers therapists around
these pro teams so say we're playing
Kansas City you know in Patriots on a
Sunday night you could do the game
you're there NFL makes you fly out
Saturday morning so you leave your
family Saturday morning I'd leave there
super early Saturdays you gotta do you
know Belichick wants to know who's
finally traveling with the team you
gotta check out I'm gonna do a couple
final physicals so you get there about
seven a.m Saturday you fly out get to
Kansas City take the two planes one or
two planes and private
contracted plane now they have their own
plane or a lot of teams do
in Kansas City you're hanging out you do
the game it's a Sunday night game so you
know the time on that it's done late
about an hour later you're hour and a
half after the game you're aboard the
plane flying back to Providence and you
landed about four or five a.m maybe with
a couple hours of sleep
and then you're going to work the next
morning and so sometimes I try to go
home and see the family see the kids and
then go to work and then you have a
thing phenomenal called post game checks
and so Monday we always do post game
injury checks and so the players would
come in after a reasonable amount of
sleep and so if you're back early in the
morning you're seeing the players at 11
A.M noon something like that and
so then your Mondays kind of gone and
then you're on then you're on to the
next game it's a it's a very very busy
life and so mine was only part of that
people that are embedded with the team
in the athletic trans therapist everyone
it's it's a very busy life especially
during the season
and you were doing you this whole time
you were also up teaching you were
teaching did you teach at Harvard for a
while we did we yeah Jack we all get an
appointment at uh Harvard but what you I
mean you're teaching residents you're
teaching fellows people are through that
you know kind of five-year system plus a
year of fellowship and you're also
trying to do research you're trying to
publish papers you're trying to do all
these things at a quote unquote academic
they consider somebody's practices you
know academic because you're affiliated
with the university that they require
because they want you to say well at
Harvard we discovered how to fix biceps
tendons better and stronger with this
thing and fix that Etc and so we publish
on that and that's what they'd like you
to do and it's part of the quote-unquote
academic requirement if you will so that
there's a lot of there's a lot of
responsibilities I mean I I love it but
you know part of that conscious decision
was to you know
still do academics at stem and Clinic
where we have a very robust lab we have
PhD scientists you got you know people
like Mark philippon who just want an
incredible you know award for all his
work and hip surgery we got we have
great people that help us
you know it takes super high-end care
with patients and we still can do
research we can still teach you just
take some other aspects because you only
have so much time in the day
yeah I looked at your uh on LinkedIn you
have your CV on there and it's like it's
literally over 110 pages I think it's
111 Pages or something like it's
everything you've ever written and done
I was like what are we gonna do a 17
hour podcast it was kind of crazy
Echo that's why Echo Charles needed
vacation right just to mentally prepare
for this yeah no I I'm sorry you had to
see that actually uh that was really
just for my mom but um no it's even I
was impressed I'm sure your mom was
completely stoked no it's uh yeah it's
kind of the way we just track what we do
and and you know and how we how we
contribute to you know the the craft
we're in so it's that that Jocko though
is a hundred percent a reflection of
team and I've always been about building
a team
those things and papers we publish and
things we've written down are so many
other
people
um you know I've got Tyler zajac here
with me an incredible human working at
the Patriots and you know he's doing a
ton of stuff you know for us and
with uh you know with some of our with
some of our our business things we we
have going on but
you bring people like that uh into the
fold and help Mentor them
and and give back it's my time to to
give back you know it's not about me and
not about me anymore it's not about me
at all but all of that was only possible
with a team and cultivating the team and
then there's I look at I look back at it
and not too often but I look back and
it's just
cool to see where all of those people
and those names land and where they are
now and what an incredible impact an
impact much even Way Way Beyond whatever
I've done and many others have made and
I'm so proud of these people that I've
been able to you know help help along
the way because now they're doing it way
better than I ever did well yeah it's
interesting too because I was we have a
friend that we trained with here Dr Luke
pomerance yeah and you know I told them
all I said yeah we have another because
he's an orthopedic surgeon he's a hand
specialist now and I told him oh yeah we
have a guy coming on uh you know Dr Matt
provencher and he goes oh yeah he goes
oh yeah I know he goes I guess he worked
as some intern or whatever it is for you
but he didn't talk about your surgery
stuff he just said oh he's really
respected in the academic world for all
the papers he's written I was like this
guy's doing a lot of stuff
getting a little bit crazy yeah it's a
little crazy yeah I know Palm Ranch is
great he was with me at 17 did an
incredible job and um I kind of turned
over the reins with senior medical
officer there to him he's done he's done
a great job and done way way better than
I have taken to the next level so when
you talk about these quote business
things that you and Tyler are working on
these are business things what is that
what does that account for what is this
okay well we I
my passions now are just it's really
coming full circle you know everything
we sort of talked about Jocko is I I
love the human performance side helping
people perform better and helping those
around me make informed decisions
whether it's coach whether it's
shamansky Admiral whether it's Jason
whether giving people opportunities
making form decisions with data is what
I love to do based on what we know what
we know in human performance and so one
of the things we're working on we call
it the predictors the predictors.com but
it's a it's looking at how we
analyze Human Performance our motto is
Health matters
and health
truly matters you know whether you're
taking care of a Seal Team guy or NFL
player or an NBA or what have you
it matters for how you perform when you
come back how you how you come back and
potentially what what else can happen
and so we're using you know pretty heavy
analytics and a lot of
information that we Garner and have
garnered over the years and cultivated
to help
people whether you're playing fantasy
sports or gambling or betting or
whatever you want to use it or teams
that want to use it to be able to have
you know information to make better
informed decisions now this is specific
to NFL and you know future MBA and NHL
baseball that kind of stuff this is
called the this is at thepredictors.com
that's right and what people can go in
there and enter data into Data they can
go and get information yeah there's a
lot of data information articles Etc
cultivated stuff that we have and I
think what we've done is kind of really
take Ai and machine learning to the next
level and really help interpret you know
every little thing about
you know what how a cornerback how a
running back how a quarterback how
Brady's going to do in a performance
it's it's pretty cool stuff and it's all
about modeling and but using you know
health is one of the major metrics on
top of everything else that someone like
Vegas or Fantasy Point predictions use
things like that it's pretty cool when
you when we know how the thing is why
it's called Health matters is Health
really matters it's amazing because
there's a reason why you turn on a NFL
show and half of it's dedicated to
injuries and when they're coming back
that's interesting that's that's kind of
amazing you did all the stuff to help
people get better heal recover and
you're also going to help them in the
gambling field help them with with their
fantasy football that's right however
they want to use it correct that's right
is there any other business things that
you have going on we're trying to help
um really deliver health care and I
think in a more simplified easier
fashion it you know it's
administrators doctors nurses techs
everything there's a ton of burnout in
healthcare
um you know all of us can get burnt out
in our craft at times but Hearth
Healthcare was tough it was tough after
covid during covid
Etc and so we're really trying to help
um make it better for the patient and
make it better for the provider the doc
the nurse the pa the tech and through
through what mechanism I mean a lot of
people like Scott Weigel working on
delivery of Health Care much better
through
app mechanisms Healthcare at your
fingertips is really what we call it and
really trying to demystify the entire
care if you will when you tear your
biceps
we know what that looks like and we're
going to help you with that
how much how much how much competition
is there from Google medicine because I
am the Google medicine master I can
basically you know uh tell any listen to
someone's symptoms and I can tell them
exactly what's wrong with myself and
every other idiot on Google but uh
what's that like well how's that changed
the medical world yeah Jacob it's it
it's the real deal I mean it's uh
information at fingertips is very
powerful and for someone like you I've
actually almost joked that I would put a
printer in my waiting room you know
hopefully I don't wait too long but they
don't but I put a printer in my waiting
room so that just in case you didn't get
to print out your Google medicine and
stuff you would be able to print it out
and bring it to the clinic well this is
what I've heard and this is how we treat
this biceps and that's not right and I
need a PRP I need a biologic injection I
need some of my own stem cells I need
someone's own stuff I mean
it's really it's actually a great
conversation starters in a way it's kind
of opens the door but sometimes it's too
much I mean you've got like 10 articles
printed out you're like okay well yeah
because you can get one article that
says one thing and you get another
article that says the complete opposite
so by the time they come to you they're
like lost totally yeah you gotta and you
have to sift through that and that's
where you're you know that's where
experience comes through that's where
you've done it before this is what we
have found in our hands this works the
best and and look I want to try to solve
as much as we can without surgery I mean
that's that's Sports Medicine in essence
and we did that with your biceps it's
all without surgery you're still out
there grappling no problem and you
didn't need to get it fixed unlike Echo
Charles but twice
it was genetically weak
it was we're always we're always trying
to show those you know like that that
cause and effect and use our experience
and and Coach patients coach patients
through a decision I mean my general
mindset is said listen here are your
options everything from
three nose surgery options we can do
this this and this two years surgery if
that doesn't work out and that's that's
generally been a pretty good approach
you know at least in my hands with
patience to
give them the options give them some
information you got to be careful of Dr
Google can can get in the way but it
also I find it just opens up the
conversation really well yeah so so
what's the app then the app is
coordinate all this stuff yeah exactly
yeah provide information everything
provides info exactly right and is this
thing up and running is it available yep
it's available so where can people find
that yeah it's we have to get it through
our Clinic yes you got to come out to
stub and we can get you hooked up with
it are you planning to broaden this to
let other people use it yeah we are just
not there yet yeah not there yet is it
in the works it's in the works yes all
right we can talk talk offline about
that yeah it's really it's really close
and you know what's amazing is uh you
know the dod super interested and uh you
know how we how we deliver Precision
medicine and Healthcare so it's all the
same themes that we've done since since
day one for me at Balboa which is really
what I love so it's coming full circle
again yeah it must be crazy because
you're seeing a patient and then you
don't this patient again for six weeks
or four weeks or three months and like
what what did I talk to him about last
time and what information have they got
in the meantime and it just seems like
if they automated that stuff and made it
more friendly to the patient obviously
that would be helpful yeah correct so
that's the type of thing this does yeah
that's exactly right okay I should have
started this company what do you think
Echo approved yeah I like it there's
time you can get in
like I said we'll talk offline exactly
so what else is what else what have we
missed
I think you know you know what's
interesting we touched on a little bit
you know I think the you know some some
of the things we get asked about a lot
and you know probably you know right
here
right here at you know Victory MMA or
you've got people that are trying to you
know perform you're with professionals
they want they want to compete at the
highest level and we get a lot of
questions about biologics you know what
do we meaning
spin my blood down put in some PRP
platelet-rich plasma put in some stem
cells spin it down and and how does that
help things how does that do
um and I think that's a a pretty unique
field that's going to be rapidly
emerging and the nice thing about it
it's very precise it's precise to you
but the problem is we're regulated by
the FDA in terms of how much we can
manipulate this Blood product
so we have to it's called minimally
manipulated blood product rule by the
FDA Federal Drug Administration so we
can only do so much with it now but
that's why you see well so and so went
out to Germany for a stem cell treatment
so-and-so went to South America or
wherever we're regulated and I think
we're going to see this very exciting
field continue to open up we're doing a
ton of research available on top of you
know a lot of other places in the world
in terms of how to optimize biologics
for your Precision game
so are you doing that right now are you
doing what the FDA will allow you to do
right now yeah we're doing what the FDA
allows us to do and and it must be
pretty easy to to
research this when Germany's do it
Mexico's doing it whatever South America
is doing it is it or no yeah it's so
weird it is um yeah again Dr Google we
have to be a little bit careful but you
have well Google said that out of
Germany we have this this and this
sometimes studies are hard to reproduce
you know you don't have the same
conditions you're on the same
methodology we're always scrutinizing
that and
we want to
you know of course provide something
that's going to be meaningful that's
going to be value driven and you know if
you're gonna you know right now a lot of
these are cash paid there's really no
insurer in the world that pays for
biologics at this point I think that's
going to change but when that does
change or even now we want to provide
value if you're going to pay for it so
we want to try to really titrate what
what conditions this works in do better
randomized trials put in the biologic
versus saline solution and figure out
what's going to work for your knee and
hip and keep you keep you going longer
what does the FDA what's their concern
if they're doing it in Germany or
something like it they're doing it in
Mexico something like it what's their
concern yeah the concern I I think is
just keeping
control of a biologic uh product
in that it is
something
something that they know what the end
product is and I think you know it's a
little more complex than that but
I think it's going to change at some
point
legislation to change like right now are
they currently looking at it not that I
know
so we're stuck going overseas if you
want these kind of treatments if you
want some
you know more extravagant advertised
quote-unquote stem cell basically
concentrating stem cells so if we take
blood off your pelvis with a needle you
take concentrate it we the stem cell
population of that blood is probably
less than one percent it's not a lot we
can't concentrate it we can only
minimally manipulate it so we have to
put back in where we can spin it down
there's only so many things we can do
but in Germany they can concentrate it
you can amplify it you can do other
things you can do PCR techniques all
these other stuff to help amplify and
get a much more robust stem cell product
that's basically what you're getting
when you go over and then is it
beneficial is it more beneficial they
say it is and we can't study in the
United States we don't really know at
this point so what about the studies
from Germany
they're promising yeah I think it's it's
it's promising and we'll get there I
mean there's a lot of stuff that comes
from overseas it just takes a little
longer for FDA to get through but we're
getting there let's go FDA get it
together
yeah and I think I mean the other thing
I know I mentioned at Jacob is here uh
you know the supplements I mean I gotta
congratulate I think you you know this
you didn't even always going to talk
about this but I'm going to is you've
done a great job with this because I
think you know that you need to perform
and continue performing in your gym so
you can hang or at least partially hang
with some of these professional athletes
that I saw hanging around today it's
pretty impressive but some beasts in
here for sure yeah there's no question
but you're I mean I mean your stuff from
the greens to the you know the joint
Warfare the choco combat tested in the
Mulk and I mean all this stuff I'm
really
I've been studying it it's it's good
stuff it's all natural I use it and you
know the you kind of taken the right
approach from a supplement standpoint to
help optimize
um I can tell you I feel better on it
yeah yeah yeah the one of the I think
one of the most impressive
um
confirmations of the efficacy of it is
the subscribers so people subscribe
to Joint Warfare they subscribe to the
greens like they get that and they take
it and they've you know we've got people
that have been taking this stuff for two
three years now and they you know
they're they're subscribed to it they're
not going on I say all the time I'm I
you you won't get me to not be on this
stuff because the way it makes me feel
even the the time War which
foreign
anecdotal it improved my vision it made
my vision better I had a we have a
certain
size monitor that we use at some of our
events and there'll be notes on the
Monitor and we do a duplicate event
every six months or so and it was you
know I showed up at one of the events
the next event I show up and I'm looking
down at the downstage monitor I say do
we get bigger monitors and they're like
no it's the same monitor I said did we
get are we using a bigger fonts or
something like no it's the same exact
slides and I said this freaking awesome
like I can see way more clearly and I've
always been blessed with good Vision
unfortunately not like you or you know
not like you unfortunately you got you
got jinxed I I was blessed with I've
always had good Vision I'm 52 years old
I've see a lot of people knock on wood I
see a lot of my friends they're having
to get you know reading glasses and
whatnot I'm still able to be okay but I
was starting to see a little bit of
degregate don't tell anyone Echo Charles
I was starting to see like a little bit
occasionally a little degradation and I
was like oh no and then sure enough now
it's
time War now I can see again like clear
so
this stuff is is effective we're testing
it like crazy
um great people helping us put together
so maybe you'll be on that now no it's I
I take it and it's got even the time
more stuff has this the target of what's
in there is to the mitochondria which is
the
the energy machine of the of the cell
and to be able to provide that
anti-aging you know cellular support
improve NAD levels which is what we use
for energy uh you know can help cells
turn over better get rid of dead cells
promote cardiovascular effects eyes
heart health Etc that's that's all what
this is targeted to and all done in a
very natural way which I I applaud you
for Jocko it's it's the right approach
and the right way to look at a
a line because you know if you just sell
nad3 like that's that's too hard I
applaud how you you know I'm putting my
MBA hat on now which I did when I was
bored and finished finally finished up
during covet was
um the subscription model like you said
so if that's not going away it's it's
you know you know it's done a great job
because that's the hardest thing to keep
with a customer is keeping them going
and renewing that so I I applaud you for
it I think it's the way you put it
together but to get the line together
makes it very simple it's stuff that we
can use and apply no not only to our
patients but into our everyday life
freaking tastes good too by the way I
showed up here today I did legs today by
the way Uncle Charles okay and then I
didn't that I had call call call came
right here
I was going catabolic let's be frank but
I rolled right in here grabbed a vanilla
ready to drink milk hammered that thing
30 grams of protein coming out uh all
right I don't want to turn this into you
know an infomercial for Jocko fuel no
and I didn't this was not planned you
know I I came here with for this just
because it's
it's good stuff well I appreciate it
okay you know coming from somebody of
your background obviously that's that's
awesome to hear
um for sure you know that's that's like
what better
seal of approval than someone like
yourself that's worked with the highest
performing people in the world and is a
freaking Doctor from Dartmouth I mean
let's go so much appreciated uh what
else is there anything else does this
get us up to speed yeah I think that's I
think that's pretty comprehensive Jocko
yeah sorry to take up so much of your
time no not at all and you know I think
I think when you come back on what we'll
do is we'll roll in with like a legit
like best practices protocols just for
rec for for for injury prevention for
recovery and then like post surgery
because let's face it most people are
going to get surgery at some point in
their life uh I had neck surgery Echoes
had a couple surgeries on this bus if
you have knee surgeries too yeah knee
surgeries so we're going to get surgery
so it's good to know some kind of
protocols around that we can do that
next time you come on that'd be awesome
and uh yeah but is there anything else
for today I love it no I think I think
that'd be great I think understanding
some you know specific injuries
optimizing Human Performance optimizing
your health putting these elements
together in your own life that we've
talked about you know since day one at
the teams that's that's reasonably
available to most of you out there yeah
we and you've helped that with your
company and now to really holistically
look at
how you want to achieve your goals what
you want to do Sports specific Precision
medicine stuff these are all things that
we can help you with things that were
you know frankly Specialists of and and
really like to optimize that because
there's nothing that puts a smile on my
face better than seeing you be able to
go back to what you want to do to be
able to play with your kids to be able
to enjoy life to be whether it's a full
professional athlete to what we say the
weekend warrior I want you to be able to
get back there and there's nothing that
makes me happier yeah and we take it for
granted I mean I take my health for
granted every day and and then also I
get injured all of a sudden I you know
my knee gets tweaked my back gets
tweaked whatever and then you go oh my
gosh so let's get ahead of it first of
all get some protocols in place and then
let's get ready to respond to it when it
happens and then let's get it ready to
recover from it those are
things you got to do things you got to
do Echo Charles yes sir you got any
questions yes because I know you're over
there football we got surgeries what do
you got you're taking notes yeah yeah uh
so you know so I talked to Dr Luke about
this every once in a while where
you know a typical person they see like
an injury you know on Instagram you know
like Dean likes to post these ones the
gymnastics get her gets her uh
gymnastics practitioner gets her need
bent back right
me like a lot of people we see that kind
of stuff and we're like Brad I want to
look at that it like makes you quit you
know you can't look at that kind of
stuff but was that ever a problem for
you and then if so how did you uh get
past it
yeah you know Echo Charles the first
real up and close I had of that was in
the cadaver Lab at Dartmouth in Hanover
New Hampshire and you walk in you've got
this
40 cadavers I mean it's it's a human
body deceased and filled with
formaldehyde and so you walk in and
you've got this
forever etched in my brain smell of
formaldehyde in the cadaver lab in the
basement of Dartmouth medical school and
you're starting to cut open someone's
skull to get at their brain and
you get over it pretty quickly I'll tell
you you have to and if you don't
um
it's pretty hard to study anatomy and
pass anatomy and get through medical
school so but I mean there's nothing
that really there's no like cadaver Prep
course it's just I mean they tell you
how to you know what's going to go on
and what to expect and things like that
and I with the injuries I'll I'll tell
you what's what's really important is
um you know you talk about this knee
bent backwards and things like that so
on the sideline just so you know we have
you know there's a ton of healthcare
professionals outside of a NFL game but
we also have access to the video of the
injury right yeah let's see exactly what
powerful super powerful to be able to
analyze it you know Jim Whalen had
trainer he's like okay check check uh
so-and-so's me out okay check the knee
do this go check the video I'll I'll
take care Oh Come Back go to a video
video and come back video and come back
so I get you know zajac here he's
helping me out we're gonna be here on
the sideline we get everything dialed
but that video of the injury you know
and obviously the since stationalized
ones and these you know bent back knees
and all the tough ones we see or the bad
ankle the fractured dislocations and
blood on the field or in the ring or
cage match or whatever you have is you
know is all there it's part of some of
these Sports yeah yeah you would like
this job because you watch that over and
over again see what happens
yeah two things on this my daughter just
graduated from Cal Poly and she was she
had cadaver labs and she would kind of
like text me I was just cutting open a
cadaver that's number one number two she
just got hurt doing doing the Jiu Jitsu
she was rolling with tabs you know tabs
yeah Alex and I was videoing you know
just like just like showed up I was kind
of on the mat just videoing and she got
her toe
like he landed on her foot and her toe
got bent all the way up to touch the top
of her foot I have it on video
and I watch the video because I couldn't
really tell what happened yeah and I
watched the video I was like oh no like
this is bad internal she's like you know
she's young and she's very athletic and
she just healed like Wolverine blood
sure she's pretty much good to go now
it's in her DNA but I watched it and I
go I was like oh my gosh she's injured
like this is gonna be a long time and
she wouldn't watch it
yeah I'll show it to you later no thank
you thank you but is it is it worse so I
think the and this is me personally like
the cadaver part that's less squeamish
than the injury especially when it
happens but you know like okay so great
train right X-ray tech so he and he's in
the trauma center trauma so he sees all
the car accident people and you know the
the femur sticking or the TBS sticking
out of the leg like that kind of stuff
so that stuff messes me up or that kind
but the dead people and that's not as
much or like even like the cutting open
I think not as much but just like the
crazy trauma part of it is there do you
lean towards one as being like less
sensitive or at least as far as like
what what gets to you back in the day
yeah no I think no it's just none of
that really faces I mean I would say
probably most you know North Phoenix
Arizona because you're just you know
you're conditioned to it you're part of
it you're in the system it certainly may
you know certainly may at first you know
I will you know some of the you know you
mentioned it earlier so some of the
things that still give me a little bit
is you know some of the we use special
instruments to cauterize or you know
some of the
burning flesh reminds me of oh yeah you
know the Wounded Warrior blown off limb
type days that that's what personally
still gets me which is you know pretty
heavy for me personally and I know many
of my colleagues as well but it's you
kind of get used to it how about when
you're just breaking out like a chisel
and a hammer yeah because that's what
you do right yeah no of course the first
thing I look at is how sharp it is like
I'm like how okay is this something
sharp is this thing got a good blade
because you know sometimes you you know
you dinged it on something or the bone
is super hard and the thing's dull and
I'm like oh I gotta I got another chisel
because that's what you're doing like
you're you're yeah like you're gonna do
a knee replacement surgery on someone
you gotta hack through some bone yeah
yeah you need you need good chisels you
gotta hack through you need
we have we have whatever business I got
you you just lost
we're elegant we're elegant about it but
the the way to be elegant is to have
great instrumentation I mean we are our
drills our Burrs our saws and things
like that I mean these are a surgical
level I mean they're really really nice
and super high RPMs and dremels that are
like at 50
000 70 000 RPM so it spins so fast that
it doesn't wrap up tissue it doesn't
wrap up a nerve or wrap up a vessel and
cause all kinds of harm so we have some
we have some pretty cool stuff it's
expensive like what is this this stuff's
you know it's expensive drills are
probably
uh twenty Thirty forty thousand dollars
oh yeah yes to have the DeWalt doesn't
cut it doesn't get bad do you think it
would but they'll Milwaukee yeah it
doesn't expensive so if you um okay so
you you're doing a surgery I don't know
shoulder right and do you see that as
just more of a specimen more so than
like oh this is a person's shoulder and
you're relating it to your own children
all this stuff whatever it's just more
like a like a diet not a diagram but
like a specimen you know that's how you
see it yeah I think it yeah I think it's
Attica Charles you're you're following
the process for what this patient has to
get them better and you know we all want
our patients to do well and so we're
trying to follow the process understand
we're doing ahead of time you know we're
meeting you again right before surgery
right before you go to sleep and so
that's very for me it's very personal
it's still you know you want that and
everyone's got a little bit different
you know although it might be same
procedure four or five six times in a
row oh just based on the day you have
everyone's pathology Anatomy is
different we're all human we're
different huh so then even if like you
know the person personally it's still
the same protocol for you then yeah
because that must have been weird
because the SEAL Teams you were working
with guys you knew yeah yeah and here's
oh here so here's a great one for you
and you you know you deal with this in
the teams is yeah you're operating on a
colleague an orthopedic surgeon or a
neurosurgeon or you know some of the
teams that knows enough and like hey
um prevention I know you're gonna do my
surgery next week or a few days next
week and uh I've got
the anesthesiologist we had picked out
really good really good person
um she's going to do my anesthesia and
uh so-and-so this Tech is really good
I've worked with as well or something
they're into the tech and I'm like dude
no let me take care of you okay let me
let me go in with my A-Team let me go in
with my platoon and let me know the
people I work with because that's what
you want all the time and they think
they're kind of doing your service oh my
God someone sort of cut off vacation
they're gonna do anesthesia for me and
this and that and then like did fine but
no let me just take care of you that we
know how to do at the highest level I
would not give any input other than like
I trust you do what you gotta do a team
what about um as far as surgeries go
what's the most I mean probability wise
right someone's coming in you got a
surgery today
what's the most common injury you think
like what do you think that surgery is
going to be most likely
yeah a lot a lot of what I do is
shoulder knee and sort of fixing
ligaments or fixing meniscus cartilage
shoulder rotator cuff injuries cuff
tears biceps labrum injuries things like
that those are kind of the common
shoulder and knee things we see is there
anything game changing for for like
ligaments coming or is are we just going
to be using cadavers and whatever taking
it from another part of your body are we
still there yeah it's a good question so
you know you get an ACL tear and you're
reasonably young you use your own tissue
but guess what nothing's for free in
Orthopedics nothing's for free if we
take it from your body we take it from
another spot of your body nothing's for
free
because you might have pain there you
might have a little bit of deficiency
you might have if we Harvest a hamstring
for your ACL and we have a little
hamstring weakness if you where does
that manifest if you're trying to bring
your heel to your buttock you might get
a little hamstring weakness there so we
try to really make an individualized
approach then if you're someone who
needs their uh
foot all the way up to their buttock
really quickly
hurdler high jumper maybe a Grappler
depending on you know how you're
behaving on the mat
um long jumper so it's maybe a sprinter
you need that flexion torque of the knee
maybe the hamstring is not the best
graph but we were what I think the
biggest thing Jocko's we're trying to
get
a better biology better healing to get
you back quicker you know current state
of your heart for an ACL surgery is
still about seven to nine months because
of muscle hamstring core I mean that's
yeah I hear your I hear your breath it's
it's a lot I mean that would that would
crush someone like you yeah you know
Charles right now that being said I mean
you've had ACL right that was going to
be my last and final question I promise
so when I had I was 19 by the way though
okay so a lot different than you know my
current state of being but I had ACL
surgery a little bit meniscus I was
cleared to playing three and a half
months no none of my coaches believed it
they're like we're not gonna put you in
or whatever but all the doctors and all
my tests all passed three and a half
months
um I but then it made me think when you
mentioned the ligamentation part of it
because I don't know how much they or
how can they even test that without I
don't know some weird
ray gun or something because you know
the the test for that is like there's
all these like exercises you got to do
but then there's these Cybex machine
that like you got to have a certain
amount of strength certain amount of
strength back right hamstring
um and what do you call patella like or
reflection and and extension or whatever
and then all this other stuff that I had
to do and at like three months they were
like hey you're impressively close given
how quick this is and then at three and
a half months they were like you pass
all the minimums to actually go play
Echo Charles you may actually have that
Wolverine a little bit of Wolverine
situations
you passed we we look at functional
screening we look at all these other
things but you went through some
functional screening and and the docs
that you were with felt that you were
ready to go and you probably passed
those with flying colors that's amazing
and that's but that was a that was a big
part we can definitely get people like
you back that are super physiologic have
access to all the best stuff access to
all the best care but there there's a
risk if you go back early because that
ligamentization of biology hasn't fully
taken hold and that that rupture risk of
your ACL is probably highest between
three
five months three in six months maybe a
little bit longer why because the
because the muscles are so strong and
stuff but the ligamentation is weak kind
of a scenario yeah the body just hasn't
fully healed the bone and your muscles
are weak like you said yeah it's bad
thanks
is what I heard yeah
no no well I thought maybe the muscles
are strong but the ligament you know so
I might be out there running routes or
whatever make a cut and my muscles can
do it but the you know how lucky
ligaments kind of hold your bone where
they do hold your bone together so my
bone might slide in a way that yep
that's another claim from Echo Charles
he claims to have loose knees is that a
thing it is yeah they're yeah hyper
hyper relaxing I'll totally let you
check it yeah and you can be like hey
these are released I mean or whatever
your conclusion is
um but the uh one key factor is I focus
super super hard on the on the physical
therapy like I treated it like a workout
program
yeah and I think you're a testament to
if you want to get back from injury from
surgery from non-operative whatever is
quick as possible you have to you have
to spend the time because
it's the body shuts down it's not your
fault but it's what we call
proprioception or how you know where
your joint is behaving in space and
these other things and how your kinetic
chain is just kind of shut down you got
your kinetic chain back really quickly
Echo Charles and that's that's a
testament to who you are and and and
what you did but for those listening if
you want to do this you don't want to
overdo it and you still have to follow
recommendations and follow the protocol
but you can get yourself back officially
and safely through these means
awesome good to meet you in person
um so where can people find you we
you're on you're on Twitter and
Instagram you're at doctorproventure
um you're on Facebook
at math youproventure MD you're on
you've got a YouTube channel we do not
highly active right now nope it is there
you're probably working it it's coming
that's uh probably by the time you hear
this will be more a little more active
Matthew provencher 28.
that's right 28 what's that 28 have to
do with I don't know what that is yeah
it's your YouTube channel your name's on
it and you're in the YouTube videos yeah
so it's definitely me yeah so we so we
another one of my side job businesses is
where the uh in our third year of
working with Fox Sports as their
director of performance and injury
analytics and so
we've been going up to LA in the Fox
Sports Studios and working really
closely with them to help uh especially
on their digital media side to do injury
interpretations how does what does it
look like when Mahomes
hurts his ankle in playoffs what's gonna
look like for the Super Bowl I was a
super gonna be firm so we do a lot of
analytics we do a lot of uh broadcast we
do podcasts we do video all affiliated
with Fox Sports so so all that stuff can
be found on Fox Sports and Fox Sports as
well and thepredictors.com and you know
also at the Steadman Clinic
uh Matthew provencher md.com as well
Matthew
preventer.com is like your main place
you can find these other things linked
from exactly yeah awesome that's where
we can find you thank you Doctor any
closing thoughts from you no I just I
just want to you know thank you you know
everyone that's been a part of this
journey it's truly been
um humbling when you know someone was
not gonna be able to fly the jet back in
the day and this kid from New Hampshire
in the sticks that has now been to 50
countries and seen the world you know to
inspire and give back any of you out
there can can do that and achieve this
and Achieve you know really great things
and I just want to thank all my mentors
and incredible people so many of which
you know we didn't even close get close
to get mentioning today but
that have helped me along my journey
because I'm truly indebted and humbled
to those those around I'm indebted to my
team my family my mom dad my brother
wife and kids and I really want to thank
all of them for enduring the journey as
well because it it takes takes a village
to to do what we all do around this
table and I I'm so appreciative and then
lastly you know Jocko and Echo Charles
really honored to be here today and I
wanted to be on your podcast and I'm
really proud of what you've all done and
how you
represent you know the community that I
had you know a very small part of of
being a part of
yeah appreciate that Doc and um you know
again thanks uh you know we we're
talking to you but as you said I know
and you know the many hundreds of people
that have participated in in making all
this stuff happen uh so thanks to all
those people thanks to you for coming
down thanks for joining us
um most important thanks for your
service you know we barely touched on 27
years in the U.S Navy that's just
awesome and what you were doing that
whole time
taking care of our wounded and our
injured warriors uh I know so many
friends that you literally personally
took care of and got them either back on
the battlefield or to live the best
possible life that they could live with
the wounds that they received so thanks
for all you did for us and thanks for
all your continuing to do now to uh make
people healthy I don't think there's any
greater service than that so thanks for
everything doc Jaco thanks a lot Health
matters and let's keep the journey going
appreciate it appreciate it thank you
and with that doc preventer has left the
building
got to stay healthy equiternals yes and
then if you take a hit you got to get
back get back in the game need to
be on the path need to stay on the path
it's a big part of being on the path
it's true
he mentioned something that I it took me
like probably a good 10 minutes to kind
of
not
kind of clarify it in my own head and it
was this where he was like and he spoke
about his maybe early experience where
he maybe implied or whatever that he was
kind of surprised that the that the guys
want wanted so much to get back onto the
battlefield when it's like dude you
you're all jammed up it's kind of like
why do you want to go it's like there
was and I'm not saying he was saying
that but it was like that was kind of
what was going on right like kind of
maybe in his head or was he talking
about somebody else at that he was
talking about himself right he was
saying these guys wanted to go back on
the battlefield and he's looking at him
like hey man you may not walk again and
you want to go back damn right yeah like
all that is respect to the highest level
admiration to the highest level yeah so
it felt like
what I'm trying to reconcile or trying
to relate maybe to what goes on in
someone's mind that's like oh yeah I
don't care about that kind of stuff I
just want to go back out
and it's one of those I guess maybe
to use a common term like their
dedication to duty their dedication to
their job for sure and
I kind of think I was not in the
military you know that about me but I
kind of think it's one of those things
where they actually enjoy the
environment like enjoy them I don't
necessarily enjoy war and all that part
of but the environment they enjoy the
environment you know what you're missing
is just they just want to be with their
brothers yeah and that's what that's
what I think is the is the element of
the environment that makes the whole
environment now no matter how shitty it
is the whole environment uh what they
want to be in is yes because of their
brothers so like yeah and it's obviously
you can make that easy comparison to
like a sports person you know or a
professional athlete even like a college
athlete
you've been a pop warner athlete where
it's like because that's the first thing
you ask the doctor when you you know jam
up your knee or your ankle or whatever
and they'd be like hey look at the
x-rays and the first thing you wonder is
like how long am I out because I want to
you know give back whatever it's the
same exact thing but it doesn't seem
like the same exact thing because it's
as far as that little element not the
same exact thing it's there's a
similarity between the two yeah yeah but
as far as the mindset it's not like oh
you know like freaking sure I'm jammed
up but at least I don't have to do that
anymore kind of it's not that it doesn't
exist you know kind of a thing so I was
like huh that is crazy it's extreme
dedication of our military personnel
that's where it is amazing stuff
um yeah so yeah he spoke about Jocko
fuel yeah he did yeah so hey man that
does man that's a big part of it
nutrition supplementation all this stuff
getting staying on the path uh getting
on the path staying on the path getting
back on the path trust me it's a big one
yeah well yeah like you said he talked
about it and uh not much I can say to to
double down on all the stuff that he was
talking about just the you know he and
he brought like a whole review he
brought like a whole typed out review of
all of our different supplements and
like what the benefits were and how good
they were it was pretty awesome yeah so
I was kind of impressed too but then
after like a few seconds I was like wait
a second of course he did yeah freaking
Doctor over here of course that's what
he did that's before I think that's
probably what most doctors would do yeah
that kind of stuff he's like and that
was like the first thing he talked to
when he got here today he was just
talking about like joint Warfare are you
talking about time War he's talking
about Mulk like he's just he's just he's
just it's awesome so there you go go to
jockoffuel.com and get some of this
awesome stuff so you can stay healthy
and stay in the game that's what we're
doing you can get a Wawa you can get a
vitamin shop
get it G and C you can do the military
commissaries a fees Hanford Dash stores
wake foreign ShopRite HEB down in Tejas
Meyer up in the midwest Harris Teeter
Lifetime Fitness Shields those big
Shield stores dang 300 000 square feet
of goodness you can get chocolate
fuelner small gyms actually out there
little gyms
little CrossFit gyms
little Jiu Jitsu gyms they have it and
if you own a CrossFit gym or you own a
little gym you own a Jiu Jitsu Academy
email jfsales jockoffool.com get sell
the stuff wholesale first of all take
care of your people take care of your
clientele take care of your students and
also add a little bit to the bottom line
right make a little bit more money look
I know what it's like I own a gym I know
that it's it's lean in the gymnasium
it's a lean in the Jiu Jitsu Academy
it's lean in the CrossFit box guess what
get yourself a little bit more
supplemental income and and in the
meantime take care of your clients out
like I said JF sales at jockofuel.com
that's what we're doing check it out
jocofuel.com go get some what else we
got true got origin USA boom American
made
apparel durable goods Jiu Jitsu Gis rash
guards the whole deal stuff made in
America that's not it's not as common as
you might think no it's not as common as
you might think in fact it doesn't
really exist other than what we're doing
here at originusa.com and these other
companies that are out there that's
saying that they care about the
environment and they say they'll care
about people
they don't care about either they're
lying to you and they're trying to cover
it up by saying they give you know one
percent to the environment or whatever
they're saying
I'm giving one percent of the
environment but I'm building a factory
in a place that has no
regulations whatsoever and they're just
going to allow me to dump chemicals into
the atmosphere and dump chemicals into
the river and dump chemicals into the
ocean that's what I'm doing but but oh
no no I'm a nice person
I'm giving my one percent oh no I care
about people
that's why I have a slave labor plan
in China because I care about people so
much
these people are liars
don't do it don't support them don't
support these communist regimes
don't support the adversaries of Freedom
the adversaries of America
help the National Security of this
country
go to originusa.com buy a pair of blue
jeans buy a freaking hoodie
I know it's summertime I know there's a
heat wave going on the heat wave is
going to end it's going to get cold even
out there in Arizona it's going to get
cold even in New Mexico it's going to
get cold
even in eastern California
out in the Imperial Valley where it's
120 degrees right now it's going to get
cold get a hoodie
get a pair of jeans get a jiu jitsu gee
get rash guards originusa.com
American made let's go it's true also
chocolate store called Jocko's door go
to Jocko store.com for this stuff
discipline equals Freedom got some
shirts on there some hats on there some
hoodies on there lightweight and regular
weight not because they're heavy
do you guys a disservice there
but yes so yes jacostar.com also there's
a uh a little program subscription
program called the shirt Locker new
shirt every month different kind of
designs but same vein different design I
saw a lot of uh shirt Locker
Live Events yep it was kind of
impressive yeah it was kind of is very
impressive that's that's like it's
people just Ultimate Game is you're just
out there representing wall on the path
so yeah Jocko store.com thank you thanks
for the support on the cert Locker if
you know sometimes people are like oh
what does that even mean the different
kind of designs whatever you can go if
you go to the the website
and you click on um
the shirt Locker it'll see if you scroll
down a little bit it'll show like a
sneak peek of this month's one it won't
show the whole shirt but you get a
little a little of what's kind of going
on at the in the current moment
I was going to show you next month's
design I was gonna do it I got inspired
by designer Salon in Hawaii okay but
we'll check it out after this good but
yes Jocko store.com all right also
subscribe to this podcast subscribe to
Jocko underground.com subscribe to your
YouTube channel subscribe to
psychological warfare go to
flipsidecanvas.com and get some cool
stuff to hang on your wall that's made
by an American hero Dakota Meyer
books I've written a bunch of books get
them
I've written a bunch of kids books
look prioritize your kids this isn't
like when you're on an airplane and the
mask comes down from the ceiling you got
to take care of yourself first in this
situation I'd say take care of your kids
first get your kid the way the warrior
Kid books
because guess what you read them it's
going to help you too
prioritize and execute
for your neighbor your neighbor's kids
your your nephew your niece
your grandkid
get him these books make their entire
life better
so there you go bunch of books you know
what they are Echelon front
we solve problems through leadership go
to echelonfront.com we just sold out the
uh Dallas muster
we're gonna sell out what we do
so if you want to come to one of our
events go to echelonfront.com check out
events
FTX Council Battlefield
just all kinds of awesome events going
on so check those out we have a women's
assembly coming up Jamie Cochran the CEO
of echelon front she is running a
leadership seminar for women
so September 14th through the 16th in
Phoenix Arizona check that out
also we have an online Training Academy
extreme ownership.com leadership is a
skill
life is a skill isn't that weird people
say life skills I'm going to tell you
life is a skill
and one of the skills one of the skills
of life
is leadership and it helps you in every
aspect of life it's little tricks it's
little techniques tactics and procedures
that you can actually use
and it's going to make your entire life
better
go to extreme ownership.com take some
classes there's a free class on there
there's a free class the barriers to
extreme ownership take that free class
I'm just giving you something for free
that's going to help every aspect of
your life
we have the framework of extreme
ownership go take that class it's free
don't I don't want anything from you
just go take that class it's going to
make your life better
we'll start there
then if you need more you can get more
there's a couple other free courses but
start with those two we're here to help
you become a better human extreme
ownership.com and if you want to help
service members active and retire you
want to help their families you want to
help gold star families check out Mark
Lee's mom
Mama Lee She's incredible woman she has
incredible charity organization that is
truly
and pragmatically helping veterans
there's no there's no like mystery as to
what she's doing
she's got programs that are set up that
are having a huge impact on Veterans and
gold star families as well
so if you want to donate or you want to
get involved go to America's Mighty
Warriors dot org and also don't forget
about heroes and horses.org we got Micah
Fink he's in the hinterland
he's up in the wilderness right now last
report was he had he was living in a
cave
in a small cave with a couple bears
and he was the alpha that's the last
report that I got
so he is taking veterans up into the
wilderness
so they can find themselves Heroes and
horses.org also if you want to connect
with us on the on the interwebs
doc provencher
matthewproventure.com he's got
thepredictors.com he's on Twitter and
Instagram at drproventure he's on
Facebook at matthewproventure MD he's
got a YouTube channel Matthew
provencher28
so that's where you can find the dock
and also Echo is that Echo Charles I am
at Jocko Wellington we're on the social
media platforms we're on there
just be careful you guys know the deal
the algorithm is there to grab you
and try and
try and utilize your brain for its
profit
that's what they're trying to do trying
to utilize your brain for its profits
like the Matrix in uh the movie The
Matrix they're trying to utilize your
body in that movie for what fuel what is
it heat fuel battery battery batteries
yeah
this is the opposite they use your mind
for their profit so don't let it happen
that's what I'm saying also thanks to
all the military personnel out there
obviously thanks to Doc provencher for
coming down here and thanks
to a special thanks to all the military
medical personnel out there
there's thousands and thousands of you
in the medical field inside the military
doctors nurses corpsman Medics Pas ATS
thanks to all of you for your incredible
dedication to keeping us alive and
keeping us healthy we thank you and also
thanks to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service all First Responders out
there thank you for your dedication
keeping us safe and keeping us alive
here at home and to everyone else out
there
you got one body
get one body you don't get a spare
and that body requires discipline to
maintain and it doesn't get easier by
the way
it's it's one of those things
unfortunately I'm sorry I hate to break
the news to you it doesn't get easier to
maintain as time goes on
there's some things in life oh you you
start playing Guitar gets easier the
more you practice the easier it gets
you
start doing Jiu Jitsu Jiu Jitsu gets
easier the more you do it
maintaining your physical health
gets harder over time now look it might
get easier from you know age 14 to age
what 45 something like that yeah if
you're lucky yeah then it starts going
the resistance becomes harder
it doesn't get easier it gets harder but
let me tell you what's even worse as you
let that slide
do you let that slide and your physical
Fitness slide life is going to get
harder don't let that happen and listen
there's no shortcuts you have to put in
the work
you have to put in the work so put in
the work take care of yourself your body
isn't a rental car
in the military we had a little saying
what's the fastest car in reverse
it's a rental car and an E3 driving it
it's the fastest car in the world in
reverse
well listen your body is not a rental
car you've got one and it's the only one
you're ever gonna have so please take
care of it
and you do that by going out there every
day
and getting after it
and until next time zeko and Jocko out